bonjour à tous je vous propose
de commencer
cette commission spéciale visant à
examiner le projet de loi visant un
sécurisé et réguler l'espace numérique
donc nous procéderons aujourd'hui à
l'audition de Jean-Noël Barrault
ministre délégué auprès du ministre de
l'économie des finances et la
souveraineté industrielle et du
numérique et lui-même est chargé du
numérique au sein de ce ministère
et nous aurons également les discussions
générales sur ce projet de loi
en votre nom à tous je souhaite la
bienvenue à Monsieur le Ministre ainsi
qu'un Marieta karamani qui interviendra
à la fois en tant que responsable du
groupe socialiste mais également au nom
de la commission des affaires
européennes puisqu'elle a un rapport
d'information portant observation sur le
projet de loi
ce projet de loi de loin sur lequel le
gouvernement a engagé la procédure
accélérée a été déposée sur le bureau du
Sénat le 10 mai dernier et a été adopté
par nos collègues de sénateurs en
première lecture le 5 juillet à
l'Assemblée nationale comme ce fut le
cas au Sénat le texte a été renvoyé pour
examen à une commission spéciale il sera
examiné en séance publique à partir du
Mercredi 4 octobre après-midi
je rappelle que lors de notre réunion
constitutive du 29 août ont été nommés
rapporteur monsieur Paul midi en tant
que rapporteur général et rapporteur du
titre 8 du projet de loi
madame Louise Morel en tant que
rapporteur des titres 1 et 2 Madame Anne
Le Hainan en tant que rapporteur du
titre 3 monsieur Denis masséglia en tant
que rapporteur des titres 4 et 6 et
Madame Mireille clapot en tant que
rapporteur des titres 5 et 6
je rappelle les modalités d'organisation
de la discussion générale sur lequel
nous nous étions accordés lors de la
réunion constitutive
le rapporteur général et les rapporteurs
thématiques et la rapporteur de la
commission des affaires européennes
disposeront d'un temps de parole de 5
minutes
les orateurs des groupes disposeront de
3 minutes chacun et auront une réponse
du ministre spécifique à leur
intervention qui sera d'une ou deux
minutes et les orateurs inscrits à titre
individuel seront disposeront d'une
minute et seront regroupés pour une
réponse
globale de Monsieur le Ministre
sans plus attendre monsieur le ministre
je vous cède la parole pour la
présentation du projet de loi
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général mesdames
et messieurs leur apporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés tout d'abord je
voudrais vous remercier pour le travail
qui a été réalisé pour préparer les
débats en commission et qui vont nous
mener au débat en séance j'ai lu les
nombreux amendements qui ont été déposés
et qui témoignent de l'intérêt et de
l'engagement des députés sur sur ces
questions
quelques mots pour peut-être donner le
fil rouge de ce texte qui qui peut
donner une impression de profusion à la
première lecture mais qui en réalité à
un fil rouge qui est celui de la
protection des Français dans l'espace
numérique il est important aujourd'hui
de pouvoir débattre et éventuellement
adopter ce texte car tous les Français
sont concernés et en particulier les
plus vulnérables les plus modestes les
plus jeunes comme les plus âgés les plus
éloignés du numérique et que cette forme
d'insécurité que rencontre nos
concitoyens sur Internet SAP leur
confiance dans le numérique au moment où
nous investissons massivement pour faire
en sorte que la France tienne son rang
de grandes nations numériques alors ce
projet de loi pour en raconter un peu
l'histoire il s'est formé à partir de
trois affluents
le premier affluent ce sont deux
règlements européens que la France
apportait qui ont été adoptés en 2022 à
la quasi unanimité des groupes
politiques du Parlement européen
d'ailleurs et qui mettent fin à 20
années pendant lesquelles les géants du
numérique se sont retranchés derrière
l'éclatement de nos législations
nationales pour refuser de prendre toute
responsabilité vis-à-vis de l'impact
qu'ils peuvent avoir sur le monde
c'est de règlement j'en dis un mot très
bref mais vous les connaissez déjà c'est
le Règlement sur les services numériques
qui fait entrer les grandes plateformes
de réseaux sociaux et de place de marché
dans l'air de la responsabilité ce qui
n'était pas le cas auparavant en leur
imposant des obligations nouvelles celle
de mettre à disposition des utilisateurs
des processus de signalement celle de
modérer de retirer les contenus
illicites qui leur sont signalés celles
de partager leur donner avec les
chercheurs ou de faire auditer leurs
algorithmes celle de proposer à leurs
utilis des algorithmes qui ne dépendent
pas de l'historique de navigation ou des
données personnelles certaines de ces
évolutions en d'ores et déjà été
matérialisées on peut s'en apercevoir
lorsqu'on utilise les principaux réseaux
sociaux que nous utilisons au quotidien
il y a une obligation que je signale en
particulier car elle est absolument
nouvelle et qu'elle ne se retrouvait
dans aucune législation nationale
auparavant c'est l'obligation faite à
ces grandes plateformes d'analyser et de
corriger le risque systémique qu'elles
font peser sur la santé des utilisateurs
on pense à la santé des jeunes et des
enfants sur le discours civique on pense
à leur rôle dans la propagation de la
désinformation et sur la sécurité
publique c'est tout à fait nouveau car
jusqu'à présent seul la responsabilité
des auteurs des messages ou des vendeurs
des produits pouvaient être engagés et
il était considéré que ces plateformes
en réalité n'étaient que des entrepôts
qui n'avaient aucune responsabilité
vis-à-vis de la manière dont les
messages ou les produits étaient
entreposés
c'est désormais une aire qui est révolue
et puis le deuxième règlement c'est le
Règlement sur les marchés numériques qui
lui vient mettre fin à un certain nombre
pas toutes mais un certain nombre de
pratiques commerciales déloyales à
partir desquels les géants du numérique
ont verrouillé un certain nombre de
marché avec deux conséquences délétères
la première c'est de tenir nos
administrations nos entreprises nos
collectivités dans un lien de dépendance
et la deuxième c'est évidemment de
fermer ces marchés pour nos entreprises
françaises et européennes ce règlement
il est assez simple en réalité il fixe
26 obligations ou interdictions
nouvelles c'est qui s'appliqueront dans
tous les territoires dans tous les États
membres de l'Union européenne quel que
soit le lieu où le ou l'entreprise est
installée et j'en cite deux à titre
d'exemple la première c'est
l'interdiction de commercialiser des
smartphones en préinstallant des
ordifones pardon en préinstallant des
navigateurs des moteurs de recherche ou
des assistants personnels c'est une
pratique que les géants du numérique ont
utilisé pour empêcher la concurrence sur
le moteur de recherche sur le navigateur
de s'exprimer autre exemple l'obligation
faite à des messageries de pouvoir
interpérer à pouvoir communiquer avec
d'autres messageries sans que le
destinataire du message n'est à
télécharger cette messagerie des
évolutions très concrètes que nos
concitoyens veut ressentir voilà le
premier affluent de ce projet de loi le
deuxième ce sont les travaux qui ont été
menés à l'Assemblée et au Sénat depuis
six ans et je veux saluer en faisant une
liste non exhaustive les travaux qui ont
pu être menés par Guillaume Gouffier
Valente et Bérengère Couillard sur
l'exposition des mineurs à la
pornographie évidemment les travaux de
Bruno Studer sur le contrôle parental
pour associer ceux de Caroline janvier
également sur la souveraineté numérique
les travaux menés par Philippe latombe
sur le harcèlement un certain d'entre
vous dont Erwan Balanant qui est membre
de la commission également ont permis de
faire bouger les lignes et ce projet de
loi vient en quelque sorte poursuivre et
traduire parfois en mesure des idées qui
ont été présentées dans des rapports
parlementaires et le troisième affluence
ce sont les consultations menées sous
l'égide du Conseil national de la
refondation qui ont été l'occasion pour
nous d'additionner les créatrices de
contenu en ligne notamment
qui
nous ont fait part des difficultés qu'à
rencontrer avec les plateformes et qui
ont conduit à l'inscription dans le
texte du Gouvernement d'un certain
nombre de mesures j'ai laissé de côté
j'aurais dû les citer les textes
portaient ce printemps
par Stéphane vogeta et Arthur Delaporte
et par Laurent marquin-jélie sur les
influenceurs d'un côté sur la protection
des mineurs en ligne de l'autre que là
aussi ce texte vient poursuivre donc en
résumé
un texte qui qui constitue le dernier
kilomètre de deux règlements majeurs que
la France a porté et qui poursuit les
travaux engagés par le Parlement ces
dernières années et au final des
protections nouvelles pour nos
concitoyens pour nos enfants pour nos
entreprises et collectivités et pour la
démocratie
protection pour nos concitoyens avec
d'abord le filtre anti arnaque qui
servira de rempart contre les campagnes
de SMS frauduleux on a tous reçu des
faux SMS de la sécurité sociale de
l'entaille du compte personnel de
formation on a tous hésités à cliquer
et en réalité sont 18 millions de
Français qui ont été victimes de cyber
malveillance l'année dernière et les
conséquences peuvent être terribles
notamment pour les Français les plus
vulnérables qui se retrouvent entraînés
dans la spirale infernale de de
l'usurpation d'identité c'est plusieurs
centaines de milliers de cas en France
chaque année avec ce dispositif simple
et gratuit qui filtrera préventivement
les adresses des sites malveillants on
coupe le mâle à la racine et en
décourage le commerce de ces de ces
pirates en quelque sorte qui
qui déploie ses campagnes de SMS
frauduleux pour évidemment constituer
des fichiers à des fins de
cybercriminalité ou d'usurpation
d'identité deuxième mesure la peine de
bannissement
la peine complémentaire de bannissement
entre les mains du juge pour les auteurs
condamnés par le juge pour des faits de
harcèlement et de cyber seulement il
s'agit là de prévenir la récidive en
privant les auteurs de violence en ligne
de leur notoriété en empêchant leur
réinscription c'est une mesure qui a été
très largement étendue par le Sénat à la
fois dans son dans l'article 5 mais
aussi compléter donc étendu dans son
spectre si l'on peut dire mais aussi
complété par une peine d'outrage en
ligne dont nous allons débattre en
commission et
j'ai pas beaucoup de doutes sur le fait
qu'on continuera dans débattre en séance
publique pour veiller à ce que ce
dispositif puisse être à la fois
efficace et puis conforme évidemment
aux limites de que prévoit notre
Constitution
troisième élément de protection de nos
concitoyens un régime nouveau pour
encadrer les jeux à objets numériques
monétisable c'est je fondais sur les
chaînes de blocs qui sont des jeux
nouveaux intermédiaires entre les jeux
vidéo d'un côté et les jeux d'argent et
de hasard de l'autre le gouvernement
avait proposé au Sénat une habitation
allégée par ordonnance le gouvernement
s'attendait à ce que le Sénat rejette
cette habilitation mais le Sénat a
souhaité inscrire ou franchir une
première étape en inscrivant dans le
texte la définition de ces jeux en
particulier en laissant à l'Assemblée
nationale le soin d'apporter le cadre de
régulation et je suis sûr que là aussi
on en aura on aura l'occasion d'en
discuter et je veux saluer le travail
acharné des rapporteurs pour trouver le
bon équilibre que nous avons su trouver
par le passé sur d'autres sujets mais
des sujets reliés entre la flexibilité
nécessaire à ce que l'innovation reste
en France et la nécessaire protection
des mineurs la préservation de la lutte
contre des addictions la lutte contre le
financement du terrorisme et le
blanchiment je viens maintenant au
chapitre la protection de nos enfants
avec le pouvoir donné à l'arcom de
bloquer des référencés les sites
pornographiques qui ne vérifieront pas
sérieusement l'âge de leurs utilisateurs
donc là on se on se situe dans la
continuité de la loi du 30 juillet 2020
voté à l'unanimité de l'Assemblée
nationale qui avait d'ores et déjà prévu
que les sites pornographiques devaient
faire cette vérification d'âge il nous
faut aller un peu plus loin parce qu'on
est encore aujourd'hui avec une
situation dramatique 2 millions
d'enfants exposés chaque mois dans notre
pays à des contenus pornographiques à 12
ans c'est un garçon sur deux qui est
exposé chaque mois à ses contenus avec
des effets évidemment délétères pour la
santé le développement affectif etc
pour ça il faut que les sites
pornographiques mettent en place des
vérifications d'âge et je sais qu'on
aura l'occasion de revenir sur les
modalités de cette vérification et puis
deuxième mesure de protection des
enfants une peine d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 40000 euros
d'amende pour les sites pardon pour les
hébergeurs qui ne retireront pas les
contenus pédopornographiques qui leur
sont signés par les autorités sous 24
heures les sites les hébergeants en
question d'ores et déjà l'obligation de
le faire mais contrairement au cas des
contenus terroristes pour lequel cette
obligation est assortie d'une sanction
elle n'est pas encore assortie d'une
sanction pour les contenus
pédopornographiques et donc on vient
aligner le régime de sanctions pour non
retraits des contenus
pédopornographiques sur celui des
contenus terroristes sur la protection
des entreprises et des collectivités
d'abord cités l'encadrement des avoir
commerciaux la portabilité et
l'interdiction des fêtes des frais de
transfert dans ce qu'on appelle l'info
nuage x c'est-à-dire l'hébergement en
ligne de donner un secteur qu'on appelle
plus communément mais pas en très bon
français le Cloud c'est un marché qui
est extrêmement concentré entre les
mains de 3 acteurs qui se sont emparés
grâce à certaines pratiques qu'on peut
qualifier de pratique commerciale
déloyales de 70 % du marché et qui
tiennent donc administration
collectivités entreprises qui ont fait
leur migration verset service dans un
lien de dépendance avec les mesures qui
sont proposées nous anticipons un
règlement européen qui a fait l'objet
d'un accord entre le Parlement et le
Conseil et nous desserrons la contrainte
pour libérer nos entreprises et
évidemment au passage redonner de l'air
et permettre à des entreprises
françaises européennes dans ce secteur
stratégique et bien de reconquérir des
parts de marché puis deuxième élément
protection de nos collectivités c'est la
pérennisation d'une expérimentation qui
avait été lancée il y a quelques années
associant cinq plateformes de location
de meublée tourisme et 5 collectivités
pour centraliser le décompte des nuité
puisque vous savez qu'il y a une règle
de 128t à ne pas dépasser pour les
meubles et tourisme avec la
pérennisation de ce dispositif les
collectivités n'auront si l'on peut dire
qu'un seul interlocuteur et le décompte
de ces nutistes sera largement simplifié
je précise que c'est une mesure qui a
été portée par ma collègue Olivia
Grégoire et puis au chapitre de la lutte
de la protection de la démocratie lutte
contre la désinformation
une
une la mise en demeure pardon suivi du
blocage que l'art comme pourra ordonner
à l'encontre des sites qui diffuseront
des médias frappés par des interdictions
par des sanctions internationales comme
celles qui ont été prises à l'encontre
de RT France et de Spoutnik
la position du gouvernement qui je pense
est largement partagé c'est que la
désinformation est un poison pour notre
démocratie on l'a vu au Capitole des
États-Unis il y a quelques années
l'Union européenne a pris et nous avons
constaté que même après que ces
sanctions ont été prises les médias en
question continuaient à diffuser sur des
sites hébergés très loin de chez nous
avec cette mesure larcon pour agir plus
efficacement et je précise que lors de
l'examen au Sénat même si ça n'a rien à
voir avec RT français Spoutnik a été
ajouté dans le code pénal la définition
des hypertrucages plus communément connu
sous le nom pas très français de Deep
fake de manière à ce que là aussi
lorsqu'elles sont dans certaines
circonstances diffusées sans le
consentement de la personne qu'elle vise
sans qu'il soit immédiatement apparent
qu'il s'agit d'un hypertrocage elle
tombe sous le coup de sanction je
finirai cette introduction par dire que
le gouvernement est évidemment très
ouvert aux propositions qui pourront
être portées par les uns et par les
autres avec deux lignes rouges sur
lesquelles je serai chargé de veiller je
n'aurais pas le très beau rôle mais je
l'assume la première de ces la ligne
rouge c'est de veiller à ne pas
enfreindre les limites que nous fixe
notre Constitution qui comme vous le
savez se réfère constamment
à l'article 11 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et des citoyen la
libre communication des pensées et des
opinions et l'un des droits les plus
précieux de l'homme tout citoyen peut
donc écrire parler et publier sauf à
répondre des abus de cette liberté dans
les conditions fixées par la loi et nous
avons eu l'expérience
depuis quelques années de voir parfois
le Conseil constitutionnel retoquer des
mesures pourtant soutenues par le
Parlement évidemment le gouvernement se
trouvera dans l'incident dans la
situation de temps en temps de d'évoquer
ce principe la préservation des libertés
fondamentales et puis l'autre ligne
rouge sur lequel on sera évidemment
contraint d’être particulièrement
attentif c'est le le respect du du
compromis trouvé au niveau européen
j’évoquais tout à l'heure ces deux
règlements que la France a obtenu qui
mettent fin à 20 ans de dumping
réglementaire de la part des géants du
numérique c'est un compromis et la
France la portée c'est à dire que la
France aurait sans doute voulu être
mieux 10 ans mais il a fallu trouver le
compromis le plus élevé possible en
terme de responsabilité placé sur les
épaules des plateformes et donc il a
fallu sans doute que la France mette de
côté certaines des positions à laquelle
elle tenait alors il est assez naturel
pour et pour les parlementaires que vous
êtes mais je dois dire qu'au moment où
nous rédigions ce projet de loi nous
avions le même réflexe de vouloir
réparer peut-être ce que ce compromis
n'a pas suffi à embrasser
mais à ce stade nous sommes évidemment
contraints de veiller à ce que le
périmètre de l'accord politique qui a
été trouvé une nouvelle fois je le
répète à la quasi unanimité des gros
politiques du Parlement soit respecté
sans quoi la Commission européenne ne
manquerait pas de nous signaler que les
dispositions ainsi adoptées seraient non
conventionnelle en tout cas je me
réjouis des échanges que nous allons
avoir dès la Commission et puis ensuite
en séance et je me tiens à disposition
évidemment des rapporteurs qui ont
d'ores et déjà fait un travail
exceptionnel de préparation et d'analyse
des amendements mais aussi à celle de
chacune et chacun d'entre vous
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre nous
allons maintenant passer aux différents
rapporteurs et commencer par le
rapporteur général qui est les
rapporteurs qui ont fait des auditions
ces deux dernières semaines et qui
aujourd'hui vous présenter leur rapport
merci monsieur le Président cher Luc
merci monsieur le ministre Serge
Jean-Noël cher rapporteur cher Louis
chers Mireille cher Denis chers
collègues ce sujet je suis très content
que nous commençons le travail tous
ensemble sur ce projet de loi de
sécurisation et de régulation de
l'espace numérique ce sujet il est très
important il est évidemment dans le
quotidien des Français et je suis
convaincu que nous pourrons rassembler
sur ce texte l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes au-delà des clivages
politiques traditionnels j'espère que
nous aurons donc le débat le plus
approfondi le plus serein et la plus
grande qualité possible et de la plus
grande qualité possible et que nous
conduirons un travail le plus trans
partisan possible aujourd'hui nous
passons déjà plus de temps dans l'espace
numérique que dans l'espace public en
moyenne ce sont deux heures par jour que
les Français passent dans l'espace
numérique et pour nos jeunes de 15 à 24
ans sont même 4 heures par jour en
moyenne et ça continue d'augmenter année
après année à grande vitesse
cet espace numérique sont les réseaux
sociaux sont les plateformes de contenu
vidéo sont nos magasins en ligne sont
nos jeux vidéo ou encore sur nos musées
en version virtuelle cet espace
numérique c'est un espace d'opportunités
immense c'est un espace de liens entre
les uns et les autres de partage avec
ses amis avec sa famille avec l'ensemble
des citoyens de la communauté nationale
européenne et mondiale c'est un espace
de création absolument fantastique
l'espace numérique c'est un espace de
liberté individuelle qui sont très
importantes notamment la liberté que
s'exprimer bien sûr mais aussi la
liberté de s'informer mais cet espace
numérique c'est aussi aujourd'hui un
petit peu le Far West 50% des arnaques
ont maintenant lieu en ligne sont 18
millions des Français qui se sont fait
arnaquer en ligne dont 9 millions qui
ont perdu de l'argent dans ces arcs en
ligne et ceci chaque année plus de 50%
de nos jeunes disent c'est déjà fait
harceler en ligne avec des conséquences
trop souvent dramatiques je pense par
exemple au cas très récent de Manon
Lanza qui après son accident dans GP
explorer c'est fait littéralement
lyncher harceler de remarques sexistes
par des milliers d'internautes mais je
pense aussi au suicide de la jeune
Lindsay cyber-harcela l'école et à
l'appel de sa mère à l'état et au
pouvoir public pour combattre je la cite
l'impunité sur les réseaux sociaux qui
ne peuvent pas continuer à gagner de
l'argent sur les propos haineux et
injurieux
je pense aussi aux jeunes Lucas harcelé
parce qu'il était homosexuel et qui
était aussi suicidé je ne veux pas moi
vivre dans un monde où parce qu'on se
sent anonyme tout le monde a un
sentiment d'impunité et ça donne un
suicide suite à harcèlement toutes les
deux semaines dans notre pays ou
d'autres comportements largement
répréhensibles et illégaux
ce sont aussi 80 % de nos enfants qui
parfois évidemment les plus jeunes on
lui accès à la pornographie par internet
avec des troubles maintenant prouvés sur
leur comportement à l'adolescence et à
l'âge adulte et puis d'une façon
générale pour tous ceux qui sont
utilisateurs quotidiens des réseaux
sociaux nombreux dans cette salle ces
misogynies racisme antisémitisme
islamophobie LGBT phobie à tous les
étages et donc nous devons trouver les
moyens d'y mettre fin ce Far West c'est
aussi nous l'avons vu malheureusement
récemment à l'occasion des violences
urbaines qui ont émaillé notre pays en
juillet où les réseaux sociaux ont joué
bien malgré eux un rôle de caisse de
résonance de ces violences les réseaux
sociaux sont un espace bien sûr de
liberté d'expression mais il ne doivent
pas faciliter ce qui est interdit
c'est-à-dire par exemple d'appeler à la
violence d'appeler à piller des magasins
ou d'appeler à aller brûler sa mairie
le chantier donc immense pour rendre
notre espace numérique aussi civilisé et
sûr que notre espace physique il ne
s'agit pas de le rendre plus contraint
au plus sécuritaire il s'agit de le
rendre au moins aussi civilisé sur que
notre espace physique il s'agit pas non
plus d'inventer des nouvelles règles et
de changer l'équipe de nos lois de notre
cadre de liberté dans public de
consommation mais il s'agit de
transposer les règles du monde physique
dans l'espace numérique il ne s'agit
donc pas de réinventer le fil à couper
le beurre mais de faire simplement de ce
qui est illégal dans le monde physique
conformément loi que nous avons mis des
siècles à écrire et à voter dans ce pays
que ce qui soit illégal dans le monde
physique soit illégal dans le monde
numérique je salue le travail des
sénateurs en première lecture qui ont
complété enrichi le texte il leur avait
été soumis dans le sens de la
transposition de nos règles dans le
monde du monde physique à l'Espace
Numérique concrètement grâce à ce texte
nous combattrons les arnaques en ligne
grâce au filtre anti arnaque qui doit
protéger nos concitoyens contre les
arnaques quasi quotidiennes dont nous
faisons tous l'objet nous contre
combattrons le cyber-harcèlement grâce à
la mise en place d'abord du règlement
européen DSA qui permet de renforcer
fortement les devoirs de modération des
grandes plateformes et nous donne un
pouvoir de sanction à leur égard
mais aussi grâce à la peine de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux et
enfin grâce à la mise en place de
mesures d'éducation et de mesure de
sanctions graduées dont nous aurons
l'occasion de débattre grâce à ce texte
nous pouvons protéger les mineurs de
l'exposition à la pornographie avec des
solutions et des mesures concrètes ce
texte sera aussi l'occasion de mieux
réguler un certain nombre d'activités
dans le monde numérique comme
l'informatique en nuage ou les jeux à
objet monétique numérique pardon
monétisable pour renforcer la
concurrence et soutenir l’innovation
enfin la mise en place d'une plateforme
pour l'activité
des meublés de tourisme sera mise en
place au service des collectivités nous
permettrons enfin les changements
législatifs pour appliquer dans le pays
les règlements du DSA sur le service
numérique et du DMA sur les marchés
numériques mis en place par l'Union
européenne à l'occasion de la présidence
française vous voyez le chantier est
immense nous sommes donc au début de
l'histoire de cet espace numérique et je
nous souhaite donc à tous un très bon
travail collectif et je suis avec les
rapporteurs à votre entière disposition
pendant toute l'étude de ce texte et
puis après aussi bien sûr merci à tous
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
vous avez eu le droit à une minute de
plus parce que vous êtes aussi
rapporteur du titre 8
minutes supplémentaire donc j'avais
encore 4 minutes non non
c'était prévu comme ça alors je vais
laisser maintenant la place à Louise
Morel qui va venir à la tribune pour son
intervention
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues je suis heureuse que
nous entamons aujourd'hui l'examen du
projet de loi visant à sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique un texte
d'importance majeur et qui est fortement
attendu par nos citoyens chez l'honneur
d'avoir été nommé rapporteur sur les
titres 1 et 2 de ce projet de loi qui
sans surprise suscite un fort intérêt au
vu du nombre d'amendements que vous avez
déposé sans paraphraser les précédents
orateurs je voudrais ajouter quelques
mots sur la symbolique de ce texte dont
la dimension européenne est indéniable
c'est en effet sous président françaises
que l'Union européenne a enclenché
l'instauration d'un arsenal juridique
visant à réguler les très glandes
plateformes dans l'espace numérique
notre objectif c'est donc d'abord de
transposer en droit national les
règlements DSA et DM1 mais nous avons
aujourd'hui l'occasion de repenser plus
globalement l'espace public numérique en
allant plus loin pour protéger nos
concitoyens sur Internet la France prend
ainsi encore une fois les devants en
étant à la pointe de l'innovation
juridique et législative en matière de
régulation du numérique il nous
appartiendra de trouver ainsi le juste
équilibre entre protection des citoyens
sanctions des abus et préservation des
libertés fondamentales sur Internet les
titres 1 et 2 contiennent plusieurs
avancées significatives concernant la
lutte contre la pédopornographie la
lutte contre la diffusion de médias sous
sanctions européennes contre le
sentiment d'impunité en ligne également
et contre la lutte en face aux arnaques
sur la pédopornographie d'abord pour
rappel ce sont aujourd'hui 2,2 millions
de mineurs qui fréquentent chaque mois
des sites pornographiques en France
représentant environ 12% de l'audience
de ces sites pour adultes par ailleurs
nous avons des centaines de milliers
d'images ou vidéos
pédocrinels qui circulent en libre accès
sur internet il y a là en fait nouveau
quand ces contenus ne sont pas mis en
ligne par des réseaux pédocrinels ils le
sont parfois par des mineurs eux-mêmes
contre de l'argent le Titre 1 doit nous
permettre de mieux protéger nos enfants
face à cette situation en donnant
davantage de pouvoir à l'arcom pour des
référencés et bloquer les sites qui ne
vérifient pas l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs
sur le sujet des médias sous sanctions
européennes vous le savez le continent
européen subit aujourd'hui une crise
géopolitique majeure et nous avons une
situation où certains médias pourtant
sous sanctions européennes continuent
toujours de véhiculer de fausses
informations je pense notamment à la
guerre en Ukraine nous allons corriger
cette faille et permettre l'application
total des sanctions quelle que soit le
canal de diffusion
au sujet du sentiment d'impunité en
ligne je voudrais tout d'abord rappeler
que nous avons la chance d'avoir en
France et en Europe des acteurs qui
possèdent déjà le niveau de technicité
pour mettre en oeuvre des solutions
efficaces à même de sécuriser l'espace
numérique je voudrais d'ailleurs les
remercier pour la culture du progrès et
le sens de l'innovation qu'il développe
au quotidien et qui font de la France
une grande nation du numérique ceci
étant nos concitoyens ne peuvent pas
comprendre que malgré l'existence
d'outils fiables la puissance publique
ne les protège pas davantage sur
Internet d'autant plus quand cela
concerne leurs enfants c'est la raison
pour laquelle la France se dotent d'un
panel de sanctions à disposition non
seulement des autorités de régulation
mais aussi du juge pour lutter contre la
cyber malveillance et contre le
cyber-harcèlement des créations comme la
peine complémentaire de bannissement des
réseaux sociaux le délit d'outrage en
ligne ou la mise en place d'une amende
forfaitaire délictuelle pour les actes
de cyber malveillance seront autant
d'outils à à disposition je soumettrai
également à vos suffrages la création
d'un stage de sensibilisation au respect
des personnes dans l'espace numérique
peine que le juge pourra prononcer je
suis convaincue que nous pouvons
améliorer la qualité de notre expérience
sur internet en apprenant ou en
rappelant à nos concitoyens les règles
de bonne conduite à adopter en ligne
enfin sur le sujet des arnaques en ligne
je voudrais rappeler que ce sont chaque
année 18 millions de Français qui sont
victimes d'arnaque en tout genre sur
Internet et 9 millions d'entre eux
accusent une perte financière il est
inacceptable de savoir que des milliers
de personnes peuvent se faire arnaquer
par le même site avant qu'une réaction
n'apparaisse le filtre entière NAC
permettra dans les conditions que nous
déterminerons ensemble d'apporter une
réponse rapide à ces arnaques qui sont
je vous le rappelle de plus en plus
élaborés et de plus en plus nombreuses
mes chers collègues je suis convaincue
qu'à travers l'application de ces
mesures il y aura un avant et un après
ce projet de loin au-delà de nos
différences politiques nous souhaitons
tous que le confort en ligne de nos
concitoyens soit améliorés et que les
abus ne perdurent plus nous aurons
certainement des solutions différentes à
proposer mais si vous le permettez en
cette rentrée à l'Assemblée nationale je
formule en souhait celui que nous
réussissions à adresser à nos
concitoyens un message de cohésion mais
aussi d'humilité dans un contexte
d'évolution permanente des outils sur
lesquels nous échangeons les sujets sont
éminemment techniques mais je crois que
nous sommes capables de les aborder avec
sérénité je vous remercie merci beaucoup
on va voir un petit balai de rapporteur
et Madame le Hainan va maintenant venir
à la tribune
pour le titre 3
pendant que madame vient à la tribune on
a le droit d'enlever sa veste oui
n'oubliez pas d'éteindre vos portables
au moins de les mettre en
mode silencieux s'il vous plaît
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur général Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues je me réjouis de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui pour l'examen du
projet de loi visant à sécuriser à
réguler l'espace numérique aussi appelé
freine j'ai eu l'honneur dans le cadre
de nos travaux de suivre le titre 3 en
qualité de rapporteur thématique ce
titre porte sur l'encadrement du marché
de l'informatique en nuage et notamment
des crédits Cloud et des frais de
transfert mais également de la
sécurisation de l'hébergement des
données la portabilité ou encore
l'interopérabilité dans son ensemble ce
projet de loi est un texte très attendu
de la part des utilisateurs et des
acteurs économiques du secteur comme en
démontre l'intérêt qu'il suscite depuis
sa présentation en conseil des ministres
avant d'en venir au fond du titre 3 je
voudrais saluer le travail de nos
collègues sénateurs qui ont enrichi ce
texte et soulever des débats qui je
l'espère se pousse poursuivront ici ces
dernières semaines nous avons eu
l'occasion d'auditionner plusieurs
dizaines d'acteurs du sur contexte
lequel nous ont apporté un éclairage
pertinent selon leur domaine de
compétences je souhaite donc les
remercier vivement de leur disponibilité
et de la qualité de nos échanges ce
projet loi s'inscrit dans la continuité
forte des évolutions récentes
intervenues dans le domaine du droit
européen desa DMA data Act ses
règlements d'ampleur ont permis
d'harmoniser notre droit et de réguler
le numérique à la bonne échelle je m'en
félicite d'autant plus que les polices
positions françaises ont été largement
suivies sur un ensemble de sujets clés
cette dynamique n'est pas achevée
évidemment il nous reste à adopter au
niveau européen la version définitive du
Data Act par ailleurs les négociations
sur l'UCS schéma européen de
certification de sécurité sont toujours
en cours et la France il prend
actuellement toute sa part
il nous faut donc garder à l'esprit
qu'au-delà de l'adaptation de notre
droit au texte européen déjà finalisé
nous devons également trouver le juste
équilibre pour adopter des dispositions
qui soient conformes autant que possible
au négociations en cours au niveau
européen en prenant en compte les
impacts sur les acteurs économiques
français et les utilisateurs le second
point sur lequel je souhaite insister
concerne la souveraineté numérique le
texte actuel contient en effet des
mesures en ce sens qu'il s'agisse de
renforcer la concurrence sur le marché
du cloud de réfléchir à la meilleure
façon de protéger nos données ou encore
de la transparence les articles 10 et 10
bisa on fait l'objet de nombreux
échanges lors de nos auditions j'ai tenu
à entendre les arguments de chacun c'est
pourquoi nous vous proposons des
amendements de réécriture voire de
suppression nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir dans le cadre de nos débats que
je souhaite constructif car il s'agit
d'un sujet extrêmement
enfin n'oublions pas que la souveraineté
numérique s'incarne aussi dans la
capacité de nos acteurs à pouvoir
acquérir ou proposer des solutions
compétitives face aux acteurs
extra-européens sur un marché qui se
veut européen le titre 3 propose donc
une régulation renforcée du marché de
l'informatique en nuage il s'inscrit en
ce sens dans la droite ligne des travaux
conduits par l'autorité la concurrence
sur ce sujet je souhaiterais insister
sur quelques points tout d'abord
l'encadrement des crédits cloud octroyer
notamment par les grands acteurs en
particulier non-européens de ce marché
et qui s'ils sont en apparence
avantageux pour les entreprises tentent
à les enfermer dans une solution qui
n'est pas toujours adéquate
désavantageant de surcroît nos acteurs
nationaux et européens je suis donc
favorable à un cadre de régulation
ambitieux bien sûr sur ce point pour
être réellement efficace ensuite sur la
régulation des frais de transfert de
données en cas de changement de
fournisseur
celle-ci permettra dans la rédaction que
nous proposons de rendre aux entreprises
utilisatrices de ces services une réelle
liberté de choix enfin ce texte
renforcement renforcera pardon utilement
les compétences de nos autorités de
régulation c'est le cas en particulier
en matière de données sur de l'ARCEP et
de la CNIL je salue leur action et je
souhaite insister sur la nécessité pour
le gouvernement de leur donner les
moyens de leur ambition je ne doute pas
que nous pourrons en reparler dans le
cadre du PLF à venir pour conclure je
souhaite remercier tous les collègues
d'avoir participé aux auditions et je me
réjouis d'avance de nos échanges sur ce
texte d'importance majeur
merci beaucoup madame la rapporteur je
le fais maintenant désormais venir Denis
ma seglia
à votre place
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues
nous nous retrouvons ce jour pour
examiner le projet de loi visant à
sécuriser et à réguler l'espace
numérique j'ai été chargé dans ce cadre
dans le cadre de nos travaux de suivre
le titre 4 et le titre 7 du texte qui
portent respectivement sur les jaunes
c'est à dire les jeux à objet numérique
monétisable et le titre 7 qui porte
différentes mesures de mise en
conformité de notre droit vis-à-vis du
droit européen
je me propose à mon tour de dire
quelques mots sur ce texte et sa logique
avant d'en venir rapidement au contenu
des articles que j'ai rapporté au nom de
la commission spéciale je me réjouis
également à mon tour que ce texte ait
été aussi largement suivi par les
acteurs des filières concernées et nous
concitoyens il contient en effet nombre
de sujets qui concerne directement dans
leur vie quotidienne que l'avenir de
notre pays ces sujets sont complexes
passionnants et surtout politique nous
devons en effet poser un cadre qui soit
protecteur de nos concitoyens quant à
leur sécurité sur Internet
mais aussi sur la préservation de leur
liberté en ligne c'est la philosophie
que j'ai retenue dans le cadre de mes
travaux avec une volonté forte aussi de
tout faire pour soutenir nos acteurs
nationaux et européens en matière
d'innovation ce texte vise en effet à
poser un cadre efficace vis-à-vis de
certaines innovations en cours au sein
de l'économie numérique je pense ici en
particulier au titre 4 qui porte sur les
jeux à objet numérique monétisable leur
développement à l'échelle mondiale
s'apprête à transformer en effet le
secteur économique du jeu et parfois à
la fois pour tort de progrès et
d'innovation mais c'est également aussi
un risque qu'il doit être anticipé vous
donner quelques chiffres on estime après
de 12 milliards d'euros le montant total
des investissements dans les jeux
utilisant les JNF les jetons dans
fongibles en 2022 pour environ 2000 jeux
dit play to earn destiné notamment
au public français selon l'Autorité
nationale des jeux les chiffres fournis
par l'Inspection générale des finances
concernant les jeux web 3 confirme cette
tendance avec à l'échelle mondiale
environ 7,6 milliards de dollars
consacrés au jeu web 3 en 2022 soit le
double des investissements consentis en
2021 dans le même domaine le
développement des volumes constituts
donc un formidable levier de croissance
et d'innovation excusez-moi pour
l'économie numérique
le développement des jaunes appelé donc
un cadre précis permettant de saisir ses
opportunités tout en fixant un cadre
permettant de prendre en compte les
risques
identifiés sur cette question et je
souhaite le saluer le Sénat à travers de
ces travaux
éviter une habitation par ordonnance sur
un sujet qui était extrêmement sensible
alors nous devons aujourd'hui débattre
du cadre que nous souhaitons fixés donc
c'est à nous aujourd'hui de nous emparer
de l'affection du Sénat sur la
définition et de trouver un bon niveau
d'obligation pour les entreprises
concernées dans le cadre de mes travaux
j'ai poursuivi le travail des
consultations des acteurs des gens
engagés par le gouvernement afin de
trouver le meilleur équilibre entre les
attentes de chacun je remercie à cette
occasion chacun des acteurs concernés
pour la qualité de nos échanges
j'espère à l'issue de nos nombreux
échanges que cette équilibre a été
trouvé
et sera confirmé lors de nos débats à
venir sur le sujet à cet effet je vous
proposerai par amendement un homme
excusez-moi un encadrement raisonnable
de l'expérimentation des jeux nuls qui
tient compte à la fois de l'impératif de
bien séparer cette activité des jeux
vidéo classique tout en la distinguant
des jeux d'argent et de hasard nous
avons également beaucoup travaillé sur
la prévention des risques liés à cette
expérimentation au profit d'un rôle
renforcé de l'autorité nationale des
jeux dans ce domaine nous aurons
l'occasion je l'espère d'avoir des
échanges nourris sur ce sujet qui sont
extrêmement complexes
sur le titre recette du texte j'aimerais
également dire un mot en conclusion de
ce propos liminaire les dispositions de
ce titre vont permettre une mise en
conformité avec le rgpd en établissant
des autorités de contrôle des
traitements de données au sein des
différents ordres juridictionnels
judiciaires administratif et financier
c'est une excellente chose et une
réponse importante aux attentes de nous
construire en manière de en matière de
protection des données l'approbation
unanime de ces mesures par les
représentants des juridictions que nous
avons additionné confirme leur
pertinence je présenterai également à
cette occasion un amendement de fond
concernant la participation des membres
du parquet général à ces mécanismes de
contrôle en effet il n'y a à mon sens
aucune raison valable pourrait exclure
de cette mission de contrôle je serai
également amené à présenter quelques
amendements rédactionnels pour clarifier
la formulation du texte je vous remercie
mes chers collègues pour être attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur des armées
nous allons entendre Mireille la peau
madame la rapporteur si vous voulez bien
venir à la tribune
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues nous examinons
aujourd'hui un texte qui porte de
nombreux avancées pour nos concitoyens
sans paraphraser mes collègues je me
réjouis de voir que nous prenons à bras
le corps la protection des mineurs sur
les réseaux sociaux les escroqueries la
haine en ligne la question de la
désinformation qui mine nos sociétés
permettez-moi juste de regretter que
nous ne puissions élargir ces mesures
aux messageries cryptées et privées
comme telegram ou WhatsApp et que nous
ne puissions contraint davantage les
plateformes pour qu'elles aient un
nombre minimum de modérateurs en langue
française ou qu'elle participe
financièrement à la sensibilisation du
public aux dangers du numérique
je voudrais aussi saluer les travaux de
la commission supérieure du numérique et
des postes ou députés sénateurs publient
régulièrement des travaux par exemple
sur la sécurité numérique sur la
souveraineté sur la protection des
mineurs
en tant que rapporteur sur les titres 5
et 6 j'ai analysé plus précisément les
articles 16 17 et 18 dont j'aimerais
vous dire un mot d'abord laissez-moi
vous parler de l'article 17 seul article
concernant les collectivités avec
l'apport d'une interface numérique sur
un sujet très sensible les données
relatives à la location des meublés de
tourisme cet article 17 prévoit la
centralisation des données transmises
par les plateformes aux communes et
viendra remplacer un système lourd et
archaïque qui pénalise les services
administratifs vous connaissez tous
évidemment l'engouement croissant des
touristes pour des locations chez
l'habitant le succès des plateformes qui
mettent en relation touristes et loueur
la législation en particulier la loi
élan a donné des possibilités de
régulation et de nouvelles possibilités
de contrôle aux communes et des
obligations aux plateformes et aux
propriétaires
celles qui ont choisi de mettre en place
la réglementation du changement d'usage
et un numéro d'enregistrement peuvent
aujourd'hui solliciter les
intermédiaires de location pour obtenir
des données sur les meublés loués sur
leur territoire cependant la
transmission ne se fait qu'une fois par
an manuellement via des fichiers Excel
ce qui est difficilement exploitable par
les communes donc l'article 17 prévoit
qu'un organisme unique sera chargé de
collecter les données auprès des
plateformes et des les communiquer
ensuite aux communes qui en font la
demande il est estimé qu'environ 350
communes pourraient bénéficier de ce
dispositif c'est une réelle avancée qui
va permettre notamment aux communes de
mieux contrôler le respect par les
loueurs de la limite de 120 jours de
location pour les résidences principales
elles pourront désormais confronter les
données en provenance de plusieurs
intermédiaires de location et signalé
aux plateformes les loueurs qui ne
respectent pas la réglementation
je vous proposerai dans la suite de la
discussion plusieurs modifications de
cet article visant en particulier à
ouvrir l'éventail des données et à
rendre accessible en étant agrégé ses
données
cet outil qui a été expérimenté dans
cinq communes a rencontré tellement de
succès qu'on nous a proposé de l'élargir
à beaucoup plus de communes et même à
toutes les communes et à davantage de
données pour en faire un outil de
pilotage de la politique de logement de
tourisme des communes mais comme par
ailleurs une législation européenne
similaire est en cours d'élaboration je
pense prudent de rester dans le cadre de
cette loi stren sur un cadre maîtrisé
pour réussir l'extension de cet outil au
350 communes concernées
quant aux articles 16 et 18 y pensent
plus précisément sur le pérenne le pôle
d'expertise de la régulation numérique
l'article 16 élargit l'accès du pérennes
aux données publiquement accessibles des
plateformes en ligne il qualifie
également expressément le pérenne pour
que celui-ci puisse mener des recherches
sur les menaces systémiques les risques
systémiques menaçant l'Union européenne
ces activités d'expérimentation et de
recherche sont très précieuses pour
appuyer les services qui doivent réguler
les plateformes cette expertise en
interne que je salue se nourrit des
travaux de recherche et des
expérimentations menées par le pérenne
c'est pourquoi j'ai proposé d'élargir
encore son champ de compétences aux
éditeurs de contenu qui utilisent un
système d'intelligence artificielle
générative
l'article 18 lui fixe dans la loi les
modalités de la collaboration entre le
pérenne et l'arcom ce dernier étant
désigné par le texte comme coordinateur
pour les services numériques en France
ces deux services collaborent déjà
aujourd'hui mais il était nécessaire de
prévoir une coopération spécifique
l'arcome pourra ainsi plus facilement
s'appuyer sur l'expertise technique du
pérenne pour mener à bien ses nouvelles
missions
je conclus en soulignant moi aussi
l'esprit constructif qui a prévalu dans
ses travaux je ne doute pas que
l'intérêt général va conduire nos futurs
discussions en ayant toujours à l'esprit
le respect des libertés fondamentales
que vous avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre elle est norme européenne qui
nous guide bien sûr merci merci Madame
la rapporteur je laisse maintenant la
parole à Marietta karamoly qui vient au
titre de la commission des affaires
européennes
madame la rapporteur vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
Mordor général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs et
chers collègues alors très rapidement
effectivement la commission des affaires
européennes c'est saisie pour
observation de projets de loi visant à
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
c'est avec un grand plaisir que je vous
partage les conclusions des travaux que
nous avons présenté il y a quelques
quelques heures voilà juste avant notre
commission et il est essentiel que les
textes effectivement examinaient par
notre assemblée bénéficie d'un éclairage
européen lorsque c'est important et je
crois que c'est plus que jamais le cas
pour les enjeux liés à la régulation
numérique près d'un an après l'adoption
formelle du DSA et du DMA par l'Union
européenne je rappelle que ces textes
majeurs ont fait l'objet d'un accord
d'un accord sous l'impulsion de la
présidence française du conseil et notre
rapport pour observation formule donc
une série de recommandations pour
améliorer le DS et le DMA à moyen terme
à l'occasion de leur examen mais
également à court terme au titre de la
phase de vie de mise en oeuvre qui
s'ouvre j'appelle en particulier la
France aussi avec d'autres partenaires
européens à saisir la commission pour
ouvrir une enquête de marché à
l'encontre du réseau x anciennement
Twitter la première liste des
contrôleurs d'accès soumis au DMA
dévoiler le 6 septembre par la
commission comporte 6 acteurs qui
atteignent les seuils quantitatifs fixés
par le DMA le réseau x ni figure pas et
répond pourtant à plusieurs critères
qualitatifs mobilisables par la
commission pour apprécier la situation
d'une entreprise et je pense notamment à
la taille importante de la société
détenu par Monsieur musc ou aux effets
de réseau qui caractérisent la
plateforme l'Allemagne en décembre
2022 appelé à désigner le réseau x comme
contrôleur d'accès et sans succès à ce
stade et donc la France est-elle prête à
se joindre un petit peu à cette démarche
qui est partagée à part d'autres États
au niveau de l'Union européenne je suis
tenuais je souhaiterais aussi conclure
mon propos en formulant deux points de
vigilance qui portent spécifiquement sur
des dispositions du projet de loi
d'abord la volonté du gouvernement de
prêt transposer les textes européens en
cours de discussion enfin de guyonner
les négociations me semblent discutables
monsieur le ministre je peux me
permettre voir un peu contestable
pourquoi parce qu'il est important que
la France fasse valoir ses intérêts
c'est tout l'objet des échanges avec le
Conseil et au Conseil européen en
revanche la pratique de la
prétransposition crée un risque
d'incompatibilité native ou prématurée à
vouloir tordre le bras de ses
partenaires peut-être on risque d'être
d'avoir notre bras attendu j'en veux
pour preuve l'encadrement des crédits
cloud qui figurent dans le projet de loi
déposé en mai mais qui a écarter du
compromis trouvé par l'union avec sur la
data acte en juin donc c'est on est ici
pour justement et éviter tous ces tous
ces problèmes la France n'a d'autre
choix que de remanier donc aujourd'hui
largement ces mesures au détriment des
impératifs de qualité et de
prévisibilité du droit et d'autre part
je m'inquiète du risque de contrariété
avec
le droit de l'Union qui frappe certaines
dispositions du projet de loi le
gouvernement propose par exemple de
nommer la nécesscrf parmi les autorités
nationales compétentes chargées de la
mise en oeuvre du DSA et ce alors même
que le considérant 112 du DSA précise
que les entités désignées doivent agir
en toute indépendance et ne pas recevoir
d'instruction y compris du gouvernement
donc vous comprendrez que la DC CRF
c'est un service de Bercy qui agit sous
l'autorité de son ministre de tutelle ma
question donc monsieur le ministre et
bien sûr elle qui a été posée dans
discussion que nous savons que les
affaires européens tout à l'heure c'est
que est-ce que le gouvernement a-t-il
tenu compte des alertes informelles que
la Commission lui a adressé dans le
cadre de procédures de notification
c'est important pour pouvoir aussi
commencer à travailler aussi sur la
suite et de façon générale comme je l'ai
évoqué ce matin dans le rapport présenté
il y a le regret que la négociation et
l'adoption des textes européens aussi
structurant pour l'avenir de nos
concitoyens se déroule quelquefois à
l'écart des Parlement nationaux
c'est-à-dire des échanges et discussions
que ce soit au niveau européen mais que
le parlement national ne sont pas
suffisamment associés pour pouvoir
effectivement se poser c'est la question
qui a été abordée aussi avec l'Allemagne
et des échanges entre le gouvernement et
le Parlement sur des importants sujets
sont débattus plus ouvertement et des
propositions donc plus partagées entre
institution voilà c'est brièvement ces
quelques réflexions que je souhaitais
partager au nom de la commission des
affaires européennes et bien sûr sur le
texte effectivement nous partageons les
objectifs et l'intérêt qu'il présente
tous ensemble sur ce sujet éminemment
important merci beaucoup madame la
rapporteur donc monsieur le ministre
pour une réponse générale
vous voyez nos rapporteurs ont beaucoup
travaillé ont beaucoup auditionné et
donc si vous souhaitez leur apporter une
réponse générale
je souscris à tout ce que les
rapporteurs ont dit par par définition
et je les remercie une nouvelle fois
pour le travail qui a été réalisé dans
des temps qui sont effectivement
qui ont été relativement restreints
je j'ai vu à quel point le rythme des
travaux avait été intense je m'arrête
une minute sur le rapport pour avis de
la commission des affaires européennes
en
saluant cette initiative et en
souhaitant que d'autres puissent
intervenir à étape régulière pas
seulement un an après l'adoption des
règlements mais aussi en amont c'est une
pratique que
le Sénat a tendance à développer un peu
plus que l'Assemblée nationale et je
pense que c'est pourtant très utile
notamment parce que au-delà des clivages
partisans il y a des positions que la
France porte et que les négociateurs
pour la France quel que soit leur niveau
que ce soit au niveau des services ou au
niveau politique pourraient mobiliser
pour et bien faire connaître les
positions de la France
vous évoquez enfin vous
évoquez la possibilité pour la France
comme l'Allemagne l'a fait n'insister
pour que X soit désigné contre heure
d'accès par la commission je signale que
d'ores et déjà puisque nous les avons
interrogé dans la sens les services de
la Commission travail à une nouvelle
vague de désignation de
contrôleur d'accès au sens du du DMA du
Règlement sur les marchés numériques
dont x pourrait faire partie ainsi que
d'autres
entreprises de services numériques sur
la prétransposition des des règlements
je je
je vous rejoins sur le fait que c'est
peut-être pas la manière la plus la plus
élégante de légiférer mais c'est une
pratique qui est assurément plus
solide ou en tout cas plus plus certaine
que celle de surtransposer pour
anticiper sur le sur votre dernière
question et à ce stade on a on a eu
l'occasion de le faire partiellement y
compris sur le DSA dans le cadre de la
discussion sur les projets de loi sur
les valeurs de la République sans que la
conventionnalité des mesures
prétransposées ne soient contestées par
les acteurs réguliers auprès de la
Commission européenne ou des
juridictions compétentes
sur les
alertes que vous évoquez de la
DGCCRF tous les concernant la dgcca tous
les garde-fous ont été mis en oeuvre
pour assurer
l'indépendance de
cette organisation pour qu'elle puisse
exercer ses fonctions dans les
conditions qui ont été prévues par
législateur européen et le Conseil
d'État évidemment à valider l'approche
retenue en définitive puisque je le
précise dans un exercice comme celui
auquel le gouvernement s'est livré
c'est à dire la prise de mesure
d'adaptation du droit français pour que
des règlements européens puissent
correctement s'appliquer ainsi que
d'autres mesures dans l'espace numérique
comme celles que les rapporteurs ont
évoqué et que moi même j'ai évoqué en
introduction il y a eu avec le Conseil
d'État un certain nombre d'échanges pour
garantir la robustesse des mesures ainsi
proposées à l'examen du parlant et puis
voilà je terminerai avec ce point là je
pense que
rétrospectivement avec le recul sur
l'exercice qui a conduit à l'adoption du
règlement sur les services numériques du
Règlement sur les marchés numériques
avec le constat que l'on peut faire
aujourd'hui des textes ou
de l'évolution au travers de la navette
européenne des textes en cours de
discussion le Règlement sur les données
le règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle oui la réponse est oui le
Parlement doit Parlement français en
particulier Assemblée nationale doit
pouvoir se saisir par le biais notamment
de propositions de résolution invitant
le gouvernement à prendre tel ou tel
position au conseil c'est ma conviction
car c'est une manière pour le
gouvernement de se présenter au Conseil
avec le poids politique du Parlement
pour défendre les positions de la France
merci monsieur le ministre
nous allons passer désormais aux
orateurs de groupe donc je vous rappelle
donc 3 minutes et une réponse
individuelle du ministre à chacune des
interventions je laisse désormais la
parole à Marie guevenou pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs monsieur le ministre
chers collègues il y a je crois une
réelle chance que de pouvoir examiner
aujourd'hui ce projet de loi dans la
forme que vous avez choisi monsieur le
ministre et avec les apports que le
Sénat adore déjà choisi d'apporter
l'adoption des trois règlements
européens structurant dans leur réponse
aux enjeux juridiques en matière de
numérique a été vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur ministre un véritable succès
politique de la présidence française de
l'Union européenne aujourd'hui nous
pouvons continuer d'être précurseur en
la matière et ce texte nous le permet
précisément car il permet des avancées à
côté de la transposition des règlements
pour toujours mieux protéger les
citoyens et nos enfants l'enjeu
politique premier de ce texte est un
autre sens de construire un nouveau
continuum de sécurité entre les espaces
physiques et les espaces numériques pour
que cessent les zones de non-droit le
sentiment d'impunité et les
comportements
ignobles qui aujourd'hui ont libre cours
en cela nous nous inscrivons aussi dans
le travail législatif entamée de longue
date par notre majorité notamment avec
le travail de Guy veuillaume Gouffier
valandre Bruno Studer Caroline janvier
Stéphane Vegeta ou encore Laurent Marc
Angelli s'agissant de la protection des
citoyens dans l'environnement numérique
ce texte apporte en effet une réponse à
deux enjeux du quotidien sur internet
que sont le cyber-harcèlement et les
arnaques en ligne il faut à ce titre
saluer le travail réalisé par les
sénateurs en première lecture qui ont
renforcé ce premier pilier notamment par
la création d'outrage en ligne qui
pourrait faire l'objet d'une sanction
immédiate par le biais de la menthe
forfaitaire délictuelle que nous ne
proposerons de réécrire pour garantir sa
valse juridique ce dispositif doit être
maintenu lorsqu'il permet d'apporter une
réponse efficace à des comportements qui
nuisent à la tranquillité de nos
concitoyens en forme comme adulte dans
des espaces numériques
s'agissant de la protection de l'enfance
en ligne nous ne pouvons que constater
que le site pornographique ont refusé
jusqu'à l'ordre de mettre en place les
outils voulus par les pouvoirs publics
pour protéger nos enfants qui se
retrouvent de plus en plus jeunes
exposées à des représentés
représentations qui construisent une
image fausse de ce que peut être une
sexualité respectueuse et épanouie qui
les enferme dans des présupposés
sexistes ou des injonctions dangereuses
face à cette menace que représente ces
contenus pour nos enfants au-delà des
mesures qui cibleront particulièrement
ces sites nous devons également
permettre aux parents d'acquérir les
outils propres à aider leurs enfants
face à ces dangers de la même façon que
le rôle des parents est de surveiller
contribuer au développement harmonieux
de leurs enfants dans la vie réelle ce
contrôle doit se poursuivre dans
l'espace numérique les propositions qui
ont été faites en ce sens vont dans la
bonne direction et nous nous proposerons
de les renforcer s'agissant enfin du
renforcement de la confiance la
souveraineté et la concurrence dans
l'économie de la dénée la transposition
des règlements européens des sa Dr et
DMA est une formidable opportunité de
renforcer l'indépendance de l'entreprise
et de favoriser l'attractivité de
l'offre Cloud françaises car et je
conclus par là nous continuons de penser
que les nouvelles opportunités
économiques offertes par le numérique
sont de véritables chances pour
l'écosystème de notre pays et de
l'Europe sachons saisir cette
opportunité tout en faisant en sorte que
la tranquillité et la sécurité se
diffuse dans ces nouveaux espaces merci
merci beaucoup je laisse désormais la
parole à Aurélien Lopez
le président nouvelle fois je
souscris madame la députée à ce que vous
avez évoqué il est vrai que il nous faut
trouver les moyens même si ce n'est pas
simple de
créer les dispositifs qui nous
permettront à la fois
efficacement et tout en veillant au
respect des libertés fondamentales de
sanctionner plus vite les auteurs de de
n en ligne pour répondre à ce que sur le
rapporteur général évoqué dans son
introduction c'est-à-dire une forme
d'impunité en ligne même si il y a des
sanctions qui sont prononcées mais une
un sentiment d'impunité en ligne auquel
il faut que nous puissions mettre fin et
je vous rejoins également sur le
deuxième point qui est celui de la
confiance c'est un terme que je n'ai pas
évoqué dans mon introduction mais qui à
mon avis est effectivement central si
nous voulons réussir et donner à nos
entreprises
les les opportunités qu'offre le
numérique il faut que ça puisse se faire
en confiance et c'est évidemment avec
les mesures d'AD aptation du droit
français au DMA avec les mesures qui
concernent l'info numérique et bien l'un
des objectifs centraux poursuivi par le
texte
merci donc maintenant je laisse la
parole à Aurélien Lopez ligori pour le
groupe rassemblement national
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous examinons aujourd'hui le
texte sécurisé et réguler l'espace
numérique qui balait pêle-mêle
protection des mineurs régulation des
entreprises numériques en ligne et bien
d'autres sujets dans les mesures que
nous soutenons dans ce texte il y avait
entendu l'article 10 bisa qui garantira
notre souveraineté en matière de Cloud
si cet article est adopté les autorités
publiques devront systématiquement avoir
recours dans la commande publique à des
entreprises européennes de Cloud excite
les menaces d'ingérence étrangère de
sabotage de pillage de données par les
États les états extra-européens nous
pouvons donc nous réjouir de cet article
de même que de la création d'une
sanction pour non retrait de contenu peu
de pornographiques ou de la création
d'un filtre entièrement mais tout n'est
pas tout n'est pas parfait dans ce
projet de loi et c'est un euphémisme il
suffit d'étudier les propositions de la
majorité pour comprendre les dangers que
certaines que certaines dispositions
peuvent représenter avec la levée de
l'anonymat sur Internet prenait par
Monsieur le rapport
vous risquez d'entraîner la France dans
une surenchère liberticide et
sécuritaire vous prenez un système
d'identité numérique vous voulez lier
identité physique et identité sur
Internet et ceci pour tous a priori et
avant même tout infraction ce serait
oublier certains principes qui font de
la France un pays démocratique et un
état de droit qui garantit la liberté
d'expression et le droit à la vie privée
bref ce serait maître le doigt dans un
engrenage dangereux très dangereux au
rassemblement national nous avons bien
compris les enjeux de ce texte nous
pensons que protection des mineurs et
protections des libertés individuelles
ne sont pas antinomiques l'anonymat en
ligne doit sauf exception bien définie
restez la règle et l'identité numérique
doit à tout prix être évité et nous
allons vous proposer des amendements en
ce sens pour cadrer vos dispositifs nous
avons aussi bien sûr proposé des mesures
de souveraineté le rassemblement
national soutiendra toujours les acteurs
français européens dans un marché
étouffé par la concurrence en
particulier des gafam
c'est seulement en respectant ces deux
principes respect de l'anonymat et
souveraineté que nous pourrons réguler
et sécuriser l'espace numérique peint en
les piétinant allègrement vous l'aurez
compris nous resterons toujours très
vigilants sur vos propositions merci
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le Député
je dirais un mot sur le 10 bisa même si
je sais que nous aurons le débat et puis
peut-être un mot sur l'identité
numérique mais sans préempté l'ensemble
des discussions qu'on pourra avoir
le 10 bisa on a eu l'occasion d'en
débattre pendant les débats de la loi de
programmation militaire et le
gouvernement a été très clair ce que
nous voulons
dès aujourd'hui c'est que les
administrations se tournent vers des
solutions certifiées
c'est-à-dire immunisé contre
législations extraterritoriales pour
leur donner sensible mais nous ne
voulons pas dès aujourd'hui imposer
cette obligation là aux entreprises
pourquoi et aux entreprises pour leur
donner sensible les entreprises les
opérateurs d'importance vitale aux
opérateurs essentiels pourquoi j'ai déjà
eu un peu l'occasion de m'exprimer là
dessus parce que en parallèle des
travaux au Parlement qu'on conduit parce
que le gouvernement y a été poussé à
établir ce cadre de protection pour les
données sensibles
semaine au niveau européen une
discussion très serrée pour que ce
principe là puisse devenir un principe
européen pourquoi c'est important pour
nous et bien parce que nos entreprises
de l'infonu agic qui depuis des mois
investissent pour obtenir la
certification le sésame délivré par
l'amsi qui garantit l'immunité de leur
donner au législation extraterritoriale
évidemment qu'elle voudrait bien que
dans d'autres pays européens on leur
demande le même niveau de sécurité et ça
ça n'a de chance véritable de se
produire que si nous parvenons à
convaincre nos partenaires européens que
pour le schéma
volontaire de certification du cloud il
faut que dans le niveau supérieur de
sécurité il est bien le critère
d'immunité au législation
extraterritoriale et malheureusement il
y a un certain nombre de pays européens
qui à ce jour sont extrêmement réticents
sans doute parce qu'ils entretiennent
des relations encore plus proches que
celles que nous entretenons avec
d'autres pays dont sont issu les acteurs
dominants de ce marché
et si nous allons trop vite si nous
imposons ces solutions à un panel trop
large d'organisation et bien nous
donnons à chaque fois des arguments à
ceux qui en Europe militent contre
l'idée que nous défendons de
d'européaniser ce principe d'immunité
au législation extraterritoriales on y
reviendra si vous voulez mais je je
voudrais essayer de vous amener à
percevoir ce pourquoi le gouvernement
la majorité n'a pas soutenu cette idée
là dans la loi de programmation
militaire non pas que nous sommes
réticents à l'idée c'est une des
premières idées qui m'est venue l'année
dernière quand j'ai pris mes fonctions
mais par la nécessité de faire aboutir
cette négociation pour que nos principes
soient
embarqués au niveau européen et sur
l'identité numérique bon il y a la
question de l'anonymat dont nous allons
parler bien sûr et je crois que sur
l'identité numérique il faut il faut pas
ambitieux pourquoi parce que moi je suis
très frappé de voir que dans un pays
comme l'Inde dans un pays comme
l'Ukraine c'est le développement de
l'identité numérique qui a permis de
réduire considérablement la fracture
numérique qui a permis à des centaines
de millions de citoyens pour l'un en
tout cas d'accéder à des services des
services commerciaux mais aussi des
services publics auxquels il n'avait pas
accès auparavant et de ce point de vue
là il me semble que sans tomber dans la
société de surveillance du tout que le
développement en lui-même de l'identité
numérique mérite d'être encouragé non
pas qu'il faille que pour tous les actes
de la vie courante on vous demande votre
identité numérique mais par exemple
puisque nous allons sans doute en parler
pour la protection des enfants en ligne
on puisse détacher de cette identité
numérique des attributs qui ne découvre
pas l'identité de la personne qui
atteste uniquement de l'un de ses
attributs c'est à dire de son âge par
exemple pour
[Musique]
fusée obstinément de poser la question
des moyens humains de l'éducation et de
la formation vous prétendez répondre à
toutes les problèmes et au défi qui nous
sont posés par un solutionnisme
technique qui ont le sait et vous allez
l'échec on le sait parce qu'il y a eu
des expériences que ce soit en
Grande-Bretagne en Australie notamment
sur la question de la vérification de
l'âge pour l'accès au site
pornographique ça n'a pas marché non
seulement cette inefficace mais surtout
ça porte atteinte à un droit fondamental
consacré par l'ONU la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne qui est le droit à
l'anonymat donc vous avez décidé dans
cet article dans l'article 1er de
refiler la patate chaude en quelque
sorte à l'arcome vous déresponsabilisez
les sites pornographiques qui n'ont plus
d'ailleurs d'obligations de résultats
mais seulement une obligation de moyens
et surtout vos contourner les juges je
disais votre texte est aussi hypocrite
et je vais le dire très clairement il
est hypocrite vis-à-vis des enfants et
de par an parce que vous n'appliquez pas
en tant que gouvernement la loi en
matière de prévention et d'éducation
sexuelle une enquête de la Direction
Générale de l'Enseignement scolaire dit
que seulement 13,5% des élèves en école
primaire ont bénéficié des trois séances
annuelles d'éducation sexuelle donc pour
l'éducation il n'y a rien dans votre
projet de loi je disais ensuite qu'il
est liberticide et on ne peut pas vous
faire confiance malheureusement monsieur
le ministre en matière de respect des
libertés et des droits il est
liberticide parce que la peine
complémentaires de bannissement
numérique que vous prévoyez à l'article
5 suppose une vérification de l'identité
civile qui va trop loin qui n'est pas
possible elle n'est pas applicable
premièrement et secondement elle met en
cause l'anonymat qui est un droit
fondamental et elle donnerait à des
entreprises étrangères un accès à des
données d'utilisateurs si ce n'est à un
état l'État français qui serait une
espèce de Big Brother en la matière donc
votre texte malheureusement est à
l'image de votre politique en général
c'est à dire que vous avancez beaucoup
de choses en termes de communication en
termes de faisabilité de résultats les
réponses ne seront pas là ma collègue
Marietta avait soulevé tout à l'heure un
certain nombre de de problèmes
concernant la conformité même au droit
européen qui vous est cher moi je crois
qu'il y a beaucoup de confusion dans ce
projet de loi et nous essaierons en tant
que député de faire le tri dans tout
cela merci merci Kero monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
même la députée effectivement il faut
pas il faut pas regarder la le projet de
loi comme résumant toute la politique de
protection des Français sur internet
ce dont nous parlons aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement la responsabilité des
auteurs la responsabilité des
plateformes il y a évidemment beaucoup
d'autres acteurs qui sont impliqués dans
cette apaisement de l'Espace Numérique a
commencé par l'Éducation nationale et je
signale que même si cette figure pas
dans le texte nous généralisons cette
année le passeport numérique en 6e
c'est-à-dire un module de
sensibilisation risque de et aux
attitudes et aux gestes à adopter en
ligne pour se prémunir contre toutes les
violences contre tous les dangers
auxquels on peut être exposé ça ne
figure pas dans le projet de loi car
c'est une expérience qui a eu qui a
commencé au mois de novembre 20 2 et qui
a été concluante et qui se généralise
cette année qui sera obligatoire pour
tous les élèves de 6e dès l'année
prochaine cela ne figure pas il y a la
responsabilité du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour le traitement des
plaintes et la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur prévoit un
certain nombre de possibilités et de
moyens supplémentaires pour que c'est
plein de puissent être déposées plus
facilement et traiter plus efficacement
et puis enfin il y a la justice
évidemment ce ce texte ne parle ni du
budget ni de l'organisation de la
justice qui elle aussi à toute sa part à
prendre et la loi de programmation de la
justice va elle aussi apporter des
solutions mais je suis d'accord avec
vous ce texte en lui-même pris
isolément ne peut rien résoudre il faut
le il faut le prendre avec l'ensemble
des autres politiques publiques qui sont
menées et qui ont des effets sur la
protection des Français et des Français
tu verras là vulnérable en ligne sur
l'aspect liberticide du texte
je veux citer vous citez vous avez
peut-être en tête le fait que nous
allons confier à l'arcom le soin de
vérifier si les sites pornographiques
disposent ou non d'un système de
vérification d'âge et si oui avec un
certain nombre de garanties qui
entourent cette faculté de lui permettre
d'ordonner le blocage et le des
référencesments du site c'est vrai que
nous empruntons pouvoir qui était jusque
là entre les mains du juge pour le
confier à une autorité administrative
indépendante mais pour le confier à une
autorité administrative indépendante qui
n'a qu'une seule chose à vérifier c'est
de savoir si oui ou non il y a un
système de vérification d'âge à l'entrée
du site pornographique on n'est pas en
train de déposséder le juge de sa
capacité de décider si oui ou non il y a
eu dans des cas où
la question se pose et où on doit
s'appuyer sur l'impartialité
l'indépendance le juge pour savoir si
oui ou non une condamnation doit être
prononcée on est vraiment là en tout cas
pour les mesures sur l'exposition des
mineurs à la pornographie sur la
vérification technique de savoir si oui
ou non une vérification d'âge est en
place et nous avons veillé justement à
ne jamais déposséder le juge lorsque une
interprétation est nécessaire et lorsque
ce qui est visé n'est pas manifestement
illicite puisque le Conseil
constitutionnel le dit très clairement
la les seuls cas où il est possible en
l'entourant de toutes les garanties
nécessaires de transférer du juge vers
l'autorité administrative indépendante
une décision c'est lorsqu'il y a un
caractère manifestement illicite ou la
question ne se pose même pas et où donc
l'impersialité l'indépendance du juge ne
sont pas requises et puis enfin sur le
côté mensonger donc vous vous montrez
prenez sur les les sujets de
vérification technique alors moi j'ai
entendu un peu les comptes rendus des
auditions qui ont eu lieu et
l'idée que oh là là à l'Australie a
renoncé le Royaume-Uni a renoncé etc
d'abord ma première réaction c'est pas
parce que les les Anglais ont renoncé
que nous allons renoncer la France est
on peut le dire à la pointe sur les
sujets pardon comment rugby
bon gardons la mêlée pour pour un peu
plus tard mais
c'est la troisième mi-temps pour un peu
plus tard mais juste sur ce point là je
me suis dit si je me présente en leur
disant
si je me présente en leur disant c'est
pas parce que les autres ont échoué que
nous on va pas réussir ça va pas leur
suffire donc qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait venir dans mon bureau hier ok
la commissaire chargée de cette
initiative australienne sur la
protection de l'enfance et je lui dis
bah vous avez échoué dites moi pourquoi
et puis ensuite je vais demander et
d'ailleurs les Royaume-Uni a aussi
échoué dites-moi pourquoi
parce qu'ils sont anglo-saxons non
dans le cas de l'Australie la commission
ils ont une commission qui s'appelle
e safety qui a travaillé pendant
longtemps pour
recenser les solutions de vérification
d'âge et qui est venu voir son
gouvernement et qui lui a dit
je souhaiterais qu'une expérimentation
puisse être financée par le gouvernement
et puis en parallèle de cette expérience
moi je vais travailler sur un
référentiel
ça vous dit quelque chose le référentiel
je pense que vous en avez débattu
pendant les auditions et qu'est-ce que
le gouvernement a dit
le gouvernement a dit non Madame la
Commissaire nous n'allons pas
financer votre expérimentation et donc
les gros titres que vous avez vu c'est
le gouvernement qui dit non à la
commissaire nous n'allons pas financer
expérimentation et pourquoi pourquoi le
gouvernement est-il refusé et bien parce
que il y a eu des sujets d'acceptabilité
d'acceptabilité sociale de système de
vérification qui pourrait éventuellement
porter atteinte à la vie privée je crois
qu'ils avaient leur propre histoire
récente sur le sujet qui avait été un
peu blessé et donc le gouvernement a dit
non je ne finance pas l'expérimentation
en revanche Madame la Commissaire merci
de définir les référentiels et elle va
s'y mettre 2024 et là je dis OK et alors
le Royaume-Uni comment ça s'est passé
Royaume-Uni une législation a été
introduite en 2018
l'expérimentation a été lancée avec de
la vérification d'âge et là les
élections arrivant je rappelle
l'expérimentation c'est de la
vérification d'âge devant les sites
pornographiques donc il y en a
évidemment que ça peut chagriner et donc
les 2019 arrivant monsieur Boris Johnson
a retiré l'expérimentation en espérant
peut-être en tirer un profit politique
mais
les le Royaume-Uni est dans la dernière
ligne droite de l'examen du on du online
safety Bill donc d'une législation qui
n'est pas très éloignée de celle que
nous avons prises au niveau européen
avec le DSA ldma et que nous sommes en
train de débattre ici à l'Assemblée
nationale qui fixera là aussi des
référentiels pour la vérification d'âge
horizon 2024 donc l'objectif Mesdames et
Messieurs les député c'est que en soi
les premiers et qu'on le fasse en
premier et vous verrez les autres nous
suivront
merci Monsieur le Ministre
désormais je laisse la parole à Victor
aberdassault pour le groupe les
républicains
merci Monsieur
ministre monsieur le rapporteur ce texte
est né de la nécessité de transposer les
nouveaux règlements européens
de notre législation afin de renforcer
également la confiance du public dans
l'espace numérique en ce sens nous
rendons également hommage au travail
méticuleux des rapporteurs de la
majorité satoriale Patrick chaise et le
kervé qui ont contribué à la qualité de
ce texte et à l'examen minutieux qui ont
donné à cette exagé à la fois équilibré
et opérationnel destiné à renforcer la
confiance du public dans l'espace
numérique ce projet de loi couvre un
éventail varié de sujets qui ont fait
l'objet de débat par nos collègues les
pouvoirs accrus de la com qui doivent
être encadrées et qui doivent également
s'accompagner d'une cohérence budgétaire
afin que les moyens qui leur seront
accordés soient proportionnelles aux
compétences que nous leur accordons
également nous veillerons à ce que
l'efficacité juridique s'accompagne de
justice
qui soit attentive aux droits et aux
libertés nous resterons resterons
vigilants également dans un contexte ou
des violences organisés sur les réseaux
sociaux engendré parfois plusieurs jours
de chaos sur le devenir de la réflexion
poussée par le Sénat et sur la diffusion
de contenu incitant à la violence
proposée par amendement sur le plan
économique les mesures visant à
encourager la compétitivité sur le
marché du cloud ça ligne étroitement sur
les exigences du Data Act et signe
l'amorce d'un grand marché européen du
numérique en outre l'harmonisation
rapide de notre droit national avec les
nouveaux textes européens est à saluer
la France se positionne d'ailleurs comme
l'un des États membres les plus
proactifs en matière de réglementation
numérique à l'échelle européenne notre
groupe les républicains appellent à ce
que la France puisse continuer à piloter
les discussions et inciter tous les
États membres à avancer vers une
souveraineté numérique complète et avoir
une législation nationale aussi complète
également entre le risque de
surtroposition quitte étouffrait
l'environnement numérique et les
atteintes aux libertés fondamentales qui
peser sur les utilisateurs nous pensons
que ce texte équilibré est vite ces deux
écueils et passe au la main cette étape
significative dans la lutte contre les
pratiques irresponsables sur Internet
toutefois il nous est proposé ici de
nous prononcer sur un texte ambitieux et
il est aussi de notre devoir de
législateur de contrôler l'application
de ce projet de loi c'est une exigence
que nous nous fixons afin d'éviter que
ce texte ne se transforme après le vote
en une coquille vide et une applicable
faute de crédit nécessaire à un moment
où nous attendons une régulation forte
du secteur numérique qui soit à la fois
stricte sur les dérives et adapter aux
défis contemporain je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député vous monsieur
le ministre merci monsieur le Président
et merci monsieur le député pour vos
propos ça rejoint je vais je vais
répéter peut-être un peu ce que je
disais mais d'une autre manière à Madame
Caravan lit tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est très important que le Parlement
soutienne les efforts de la France et on
a un très bel exemple avec les articles
sur l'info nuagic puisque on
prétranspose des dispositions qu'on a
porté mais qui ont fait consensus au
niveau européen sur la concurrence dans
le marché du cloud dans le marché de
l'info nuagique et ça c'est c'est la
concurrence mais au service de la
souveraineté puisqu'en est en train de
ré-ouvrir des marchés complètement
verrouillés qui va se saisir de cette
réouverture évidemment les acteurs
français et ce qui est intéressant c'est
autant la France a réussi à convaincre
en disant il faut plus de concurrence
sur ce marché autant sur le sujet
aborder tout à l'heure par Monsieur
Lopez figurie de
des certifications et de l'immunité au
législation extraterritoriale là on a
beaucoup plus de mal à convaincre nos
partenaires européens je le signale
parce que ça peut sembler comme une
dissonance mais en réalité c'est pour
nous une consonance mais pour certains
de nos partenaires européens
effectivement une sorte de dissonance
dans leur approche de la régulation de
ces marchés c'est important
merci Monsieur le Ministre désormais je
laisse la parole à Erwan Balanant pour
le groupe démocrate
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues lundi pour la première fois en
France des parents ont porté plainte
contre Tik Tok pour provocation suicide
non assistance à personne en péril et
propagande ou publicité des moyens de se
donner la mort ce sont selon eux selon
les parents et les plaignants le réseau
social à sa part de responsabilité dans
le suicide de leur fille le 16 septembre
2021 alors s'il est incontestable que
nous adultes et pour beaucoup parents
nous devons apprendre à nos enfants à
utiliser les réseaux sociaux en bonne
intelligence nous ne pouvons pas tout
l'état non plus ne peut pas tout et
notre rôle dans cette commission est
face à ce projet de loi sera de doter
l'état des outils suffisants pour lutter
contre les violences en ligne
mais s'il est avant tout important de
rappeler la responsabilité de chacun et
au premier rang de laquelle celle des
plateformes
nous devons rappeler qu'elles doivent
maîtriser les risques relatifs aux
usages d'Internet et s'il fallait s'en
convaincre davantage vous rappellerai
notre anecdote enfin anecdote un peu
Funès les dizaines de milliers de
messages d'insultes sexistes et sexuels
reçus par l'influenceuse Manon Lanza
après son accident au Grand Prix de
Formule 4 ce week-end il est intolérable
que de tels comportements puissent
proliférer en toute impunité et il nous
est
urgemment important d'agir pour réguler
cet espace public numérique
alors pour cela nous devons définir des
interdits clairs et précis et je pense
que la délictualisation de l'outrage
sexiste et sexuelle lorsqu'il est commis
en ligne pourraient être une première
étape si cette infraction a tout d'abord
été pensée pour lutter contre le
harcèlement de rue dans l'espace public
elle doit être étendue aujourd'hui au
harcèlement dans l'espace public
numérique le recours à l'amende
forfaitaire délictuel permettra alors de
réprimer plus efficacement et plus
rapidement les cyber outrages toutefois
l'AFD ne peut être la réponse à tous les
cybers outrages nous devons garder nous
devons de garder ce cette AFD sur les
délits d'outrages puni d'une telle
amende qui risquerait d'englober des
infractions plus graves plus sévèrement
réprimé pour laquelle il est nécessaire
de laisser le temps à la justice de
faire son travail
nos débats nous mèneront aussi à
questionner la place de l'anonymat dans
l'espace public et l'espace numérique
pardon dans le prisme de la lutte contre
la haine en ligne c'est une question qui
doit être posée je sais votre que c'est
votre volonté monsieur le rapporteur
général pour autant nous ne pourrons pas
soutenir toutes les initiatives et
toutes les initiatives qui iront trop
loin car nous touchons ici à l'un des
fondements d'Internet mais aussi un des
fondements de nos valeurs républicaines
et donc un tel changement doit être
envisagé avec beaucoup de propositions
et surtout avec la précaution
ultime et nécessaire de respecter nos
libertés fondamentales alors monsieur le
ministre monsieur les rapporteurs le
groupe démocrate votera évidemment ce
texte travaillera ce texte amendra ce
texte un texte indispensable pour
sécuriser réguler notre espace numérique
et assurer la souveraineté de la France
en la matière je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député je laisse désormais
la parole à un Marieta caramel en lit
pour le groupe et Monsieur le ministre
pardon
merci monsieur le Président et
permettez-moi effectivement de de saluer
le travail déjà réalisé et en quelque
sorte qui a préparé nos débats
aujourd'hui des one Balanant et d'autres
avec lui sur la question de l'outrage
sexiste cette piste celle de l'outrage a
été suivie par les sénateurs qui comme
chacun d'entre vous et comme moi-même
ont tenté ou tente de trouver une
manière à la fois efficace et
respectueuse des libertés de sanctionner
les
individus qui se livrent à la
propagation de la haine et de la
violence en ligne
évidemment il y a un certain nombre
d'embûches sur ce chemin là
en voulant gagner en efficacité c'est le
principe de l'amende forfaitaire
délictuelle on en vient parfois à
décriminaliser c'est-à-dire à
sanctionner avec une amende
inférieure très parfois très inférieure
à la sanction qui serait ce qui serait
sinon applicable des délits qui peuvent
être parfois très graves et donc là il
appartient au législateur de de trouver
le bon équilibre le bon de faire le bon
arbitrage entre le gain en efficacité et
le la décalification de certains délits
ou de certains crimes qui peuvent être
pourtant très graves et puis il y a un
autre équilibre à trouver sur cette
question de l'outrage qui est celui de
qu'on a abordé tout à l'heure mais celui
du respect des des libertés et du
respect du fait qu'il est attendu qu'un
juge puisse se prononcer lorsque des
actes ne sont pas manifestement
constitutifs d'un délit ou d'un crime
lorsqu'il n'y a pas une caractère
absolument manifeste alors l'amende
forfaitaire délictuelle ne peut par
raisonnablement s'appliquer puisqu'on
imagine pas les autorités
administrées comme ça des amendes alors
même qu'une interprétation est
nécessaire et donc pour ces deux réseaux
il faut trouver mais je fais confiance à
la sagesse du Parlement et peut-être
qu'on arrivera pas aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'on y arrivera pas en séance peut-être
que ces temps CMP qu'elle a toute fin la
sagesse éclatera j'ai confiance dans le
Parlement pour trouver les bons
arbitrages puisque je souhaite vraiment
qu'on puisse pour ma part essayer
d'avancer sur cette question là
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre donc
du coup Marieta Caraman libre pour le
groupe socialiste et apparenté merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues
alors au nom du groupe effectivement je
voulais rappeler que depuis 6 ans le
texte les textes visant à réguler
l'espace numérique et l'activité des
plateformes pour adapter justement le
droit français à la réglementation
européenne ou satisfaire des demandes
politiques circonstancielles se
multiplient et ainsi notre droit en
matière numérique et
composé de couches successives
accumulées qui vise à pallier les
défaillances des textes sans jamais
aussi apprécier la capacité des pouvoirs
publics aller faire appliquer et sans
grande cohérence parfois d'ensemble donc
cette stratification submerge les
utilisateurs des services numériques
ainsi que les acteurs économiques comme
les TPE et les PME et surtout ce
foisonnement législatif exige de la part
de à définir une stratégie qui est
nécessaire une stratégie numérique
nationale qui embrasse à la fois la
défense des libertés individuelles la
gestion numérique des services publics
la régulation des relations entre les
usagers et les plateformes la capacité
aussi d'indépendance de nos
infrastructures industrielles et donc
peut-être je me permets ici par
commencer par une question monsieur le
ministre est-ce qu'il n'est pas arrivé
le temps ou l'idée de mettre un chantier
un code du numérique est arrivé et
peut-être mettre aussi en cohérence cet
ensemble de règles me semble nécessaire
depuis le temps que nous travaillons et
je parle en tant que parlementaire ou un
petit peu quelques mandats
derrière donc il y a ces éléments là en
fait par ailleurs quand on aborde la
question des transformations numériques
face à cette information nos sociétés ne
sont pas et le nombre démocratie ne sont
pas protégés suffisamment et on le voit
que 40% des vins plus grandes
entreprises du monde aujourd'hui
s'appuient sur un modèle économique du
capitalisme de plateformes qui reposent
sur une accumulation justement de
données massivement exploitée par les
algorithmes
etc aussi position que Pâques le marché
européen de l'informatique également un
nuage qui pourrait passer de 53
milliards d'euros en 2020 à
560 milliards d'euros en 2030 le marché
mondial du x qui représenterait environ
8 milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires avec des sites
pornographiques gérés par des
entreprises très puissantes qui n'ont
aucune d'ailleurs intention de se
conformer à la loi à la loi du train en
30 juillet 2020 bref je peux faire la
liste un petit peu de tous ces éléments
qui posent problème aujourd'hui dans
notre société dans nos démocratie et qui
demande finalement d'avancer de manière
avec une plus grande avec une stratégie
partagée je dirais en associant tout le
tout le monde donc concernant le
référentiel d'exigence technique ainsi
que les sites de contenus
pornographiques justement nous faisons
générique de proposition pour faire en
sorte que la mise en place du
référentiel par les plateformes ne les
dédouane pas de leur responsabilité nous
pensons que le moyen le plus efficace
pour protéger les mineurs en ligne reste
le contrôle parental en premier pour
cela nous proposons des amendements
aussi en fin de renforcer l'automaticité
de la mise en place du contrôle parental
enfin je pour terminer je voulais aussi
rester sur un élément qui est le genou
finalement c'est jeu qui empruntent des
caractéristiques à la fois des jeux de
loisirs et des jeux d'argent ils sont
aujourd'hui soumis à un cadre juridique
restrictif mais inadapté il convient
peut-être de le définir précisément le
préciser leurs conditions d'exploitation
là-dessus aussi nous ferons des
propositions lors du débat que nous
souhaitons constructifs parce que on
nous partageons des objectifs mais les
moyens doivent être aussi de suivi merci
Madame la député je laisse le monsieur
le ministre vous répondre merci monsieur
le Président Madame la Députée vous
parlez d'or et vous avez raison il nous
faut rassembler le code des postes et
des communications la LCEN dans un code
du numérique mais c'est un travail
extrêmement lourd
auquel j'ai demandé au service de
Direction Générale des Entreprises de
commencer à réfléchir mais rassurez-vous
je ne déposerai pas d'amendement vous
proposez en de d'habilité le
gouvernement à légiférer Parlement pour
créer un tel code ceci étant dit je
pense qu'il sera utile on s'en est
aperçu en rédigeant ce projet de loi en
l'examinant au Sénat qu'il est désormais
venu le moment de rassembler à minima
c'est ces deux mais je ne suis pas sûr
que ça s'arrête là et quand à la
législation européenne c'est vrai
qu'elle peut donner l'impression d'être
comment dire un peu dispersé mais il y a
quand même
une
comment dire et c'est Thierry Breton qui
l'exprime le mieux vraiment une sorte de
d'assemblage de de législation dans le
domaine numérique qui vont
progressivement et qui peuvent donner
l'impression de patchwork pour l'instant
mais qui vont progressivement nous qui
vont nous permettre de disposer d'un
marché unique du numérique qui sera bon
à la fois très utile pour une entreprise
mais aussi qui permettra de mettre ou de
faire respecter nos valeurs par les les
géants du numérique puis sur contrôle
parental et surgenu je pense que dans le
cadre du débat on aura l'occasion
d'échanger sur vos propositions merci le
monsieur le ministre désormais je laisse
la parole à l'orateur Agnès Carel pour
le groupe horizon et à parenté
merci je me suis le président monsieur
le ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nouvelle
espace à part entière le numérique a
pris une place considérable si ce n'est
incontournable dans la vie de nos
concitoyens dans la vie économique mais
également dans notre démocratie dans ce
nouveau champ de liberté la loi doit
protéger en particulier les plus
vulnérables mais dans cet espace sans
frontières l'action du législateur
français seul placerait la France dans
une situation isolée voire impuissante
s'il en fallait une de plus l'action
conjointe des États membres en la
matière est une preuve qu'au-delà du
symbole d'unité des peuples l'Union
européenne c'est se donner les moyens de
sa souveraineté pardon et de sa
compétitivité à ce titre le groupe
horizon et apparenté salut l'adoption
des différents règlements européens en
partie transposer au sein de ce projet
de loi construire un ordre public
numérique est une nécessité le groupe
horizon en a pris pleinement la mesure
nous avons souhaité
la première niche parlementaire poser
les jalons d'une protection efficace des
mineurs contre les externalités
négatives et avérées des réseaux sociaux
pour les plus jeunes c'était la
conviction du président Laurent
marquantelli et nous sommes heureux
qu'elle ait trouvé un éco positif tant
auprès du Sénat que de l'Assemblée
nationale mais le groupe Horizon est
apparenté à la conviction qu'il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin et poursuivre
la construction d'un national législatif
adapté à ses évolutions si rapide ce
projet de loi enrichit par nos collègues
sénateurs proposent un arsenal complet
que nous soutenons protéger les mineurs
face à l'exposition toujours plus
importante aux images pornographiques
protéger nos concitoyens contre les
actes malveillants qu'il s'agisse de
cyber-harcèlement ou d'arnaque en ligne
protéger nos entreprises et nos
collectivités en posant les bases d'une
souveraineté économique et numérique au
sein de l'Union européenne n'oublions
pas que l'efficacité de toutes ces
dispositions tient aussi et surtout en
un mot l'éducation
ce projet de loi n'abordait pas à ce
stade la question de l'éducation
numérique les amendements que nous avons
proposé déposés vont dans ce sens parce
qu'il faut être lucide nous aurons beau
mettre en place de nombreux dispositifs
contraignants cela ne remplacera jamais
l'apprentissage et l'éducation à ce
comporter correctement dans la vie comme
en ligne par ailleurs l'action publique
ne passe pas que par la loi nous
disposons d'autres moyens pour agir
comme le réglementaire par exemple en ce
sens comment le gouvernement compte
intervenir pour mieux former les plus
jeunes aux enjeux du numérique formaient
les parents il faut que les consciences
s'éveillent nous ne sécuriserons
véritablement l'espace numérique que si
nous sommes véritablement formés aux
opportunités et au risque que présence
ce nouvel espace le groupe Horizon est
apparenté profondément convaincus de la
nécessité de construire ce nouvel ordre
public numérique votera donc en faveur
de ce projet de loi je vous remercie
merci madame la députée monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Députée je sais
parce que vous l'avez exprimé à
plusieurs reprises que vous êtes très
attaché à cette question de l'éducation
et de la sensibilisation et je dois dire
après avoir lu la liasse des abonnements
déposés sur le texte pour la commission
que vous n'êtes pas la seule et je pense
que c'est je pense que c'était attendu
car nous avons dans les drames qui ont
été cités par le rapporteur général par
d'autres parmi vous clairement un
défaut de sensibilisation qui par
exemple et je veux citer cet exemple
ne va sans doute pas permettre dans
certains des dames qu'on a connus de
d'invoquer la responsabilité des
plateformes je m'explique
dans l'état actuel du droit et je parle
on est le
on est le 19 septembre donc le DSA est
entré en vigueur pour les grandes
plateformes il y a un peu moins d'un
mois la responsabilité d'une plateforme
sur un cas individuel ne peut être
engagé que si elle a eu connaissance
d'un fait en particulier d'un fait de
cyber-harcèlement par exemple un fait de
cyber-harcèlement scolaire pour être
très précis
dans les drames que nous avons connues
il arrive parfois
que bien que la victime et puis évoquer
la situation avec ses parents ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas que les
parents et évoqué ou informés
l'éducation nationale en allant parfois
jusque très haut dans la hiérarchie et
bien que personne n'ait eu le réflexe
d'adopter un geste simple
s'agissant de la partie cyber du
harcèlement qui est de signaler la
responsabilité d'une plateforme ne peut
pas être engagée alors même qu'elle a
sans doute joué le un rôle important
dans le drame que dans un drame que si
les contenus ne lui ont pas été signalés
signaler c'est un acte civique et chacun
doit le faire il ne s'agit pas de
dénoncer il s'agit tout simplement de
d'activer la responsabilité des
plateformes et je prends cette question
de l'éducation et de la sensibilisation
par ce petit bout là parce que j'ai été
personnellement très frappé de voir qu'à
leur que nous autres dans les ministères
on parle de signalement toute la journée
et bien que pour les petits enfants de
notre dans notre pays qui se font
harceler c'est quelque chose dont ils ne
sont pas du tout au courant alors
oui des actions en d'ores et déjà
entreprises étaient entreprises
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
l'expérimentation qui a eu lieu dans
plusieurs centaines de collèges cette
année de ce passeport pix qui va être
administré dans la salle informatique et
qui va sensibiliser les élèves
aux attitudes au gestes qu'il faut
adopter dans dans des situations de
confrontation aussi bien à seulement
peut-être faudra-t-il
aller plus loin pour l'avenir c'est
généraliser cette année s'est rendu
obligatoire l'année prochaine
peut-être pour la question des parents
je sais qu'elle va revenir dans nos
débats va-t-il ouvrir ce type de module
aux parents peut-être pas le rendre
obligatoire pour tous les parents de
France parce que ça serait peut-être
excessif dans un premier temps mais que
les parents et leurs enfants c'est un
peu l'esprit du contrôle parental le
dispositif que nous devons à la
proposition à la loi de Bruno Studer qui
vise à activer le dialogue parental
peut-être que c'est même modules de
formation qui va et qui va être
administré dans à tous les élèves de 6e
dans notre pays pour être mis entre les
mains des parents qui pourraient le
réaliser avec leur enfant bref il y a
sans doute des choses à imaginer mais
elle n'en pas douter nous aurons ces
discussions dans les jours qui viennent
merci Monsieur le Ministre l'aurélien
l'orateur suit suivant est Aurélien
taché écologiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre depuis maintenant quelques
années je dirais au moins une décennie
le monde fait tout pour que le numérique
ressemble le plus possible au réel
finalement mais moi je vais vous dire
monsieur le ministre je vois l'état du
monde aujourd'hui j'espère sincèrement
qu'on va faire le chemin inverse et
notamment en matière de préservation de
nos libertés internet était au départ un
formidable outil de diffusion du savoir
de communication de partage c'est un
outil qui aujourd'hui est présent dans
notre vie sociale professionnelle
quotidienne et qui doit rester oui je le
dis cet espace de liberté j'ai quelques
inquiétudes quand je vois le texte mais
aussi les débats qui surgissent depuis
quelques jours
un outil qui doit préserver nos libertés
je le disais en matière de protection
des données personnelles en matière de
droit à la vie privée en matière de
liberté des journalistes aussi qui
doivent pouvoir garder l'anonymat pour
pouvoir faire leur travail correctement
donc je vous le redis monsieur le
ministre je ne souhaite pas que le monde
numérique devienne finalement à
l'identique du monde réel et encore
moins aujourd'hui où je vois par exemple
la journaliste Ariane ladrieu dont les
sources sont attaquées aujourd'hui et
dont le journal est perquisitionner
finalement arrêté parce qu'elle faisait
son travail de journaliste si on ouvre
le débat que vous que la majorité
souhaite sembler ouvrir sur la fin de
l'anonymat dans sur le monde numérique
j'ai bien peur que on ouvre une boîte de
Pandore à laquelle véritablement ce
texte n'était pas destiné vous avez
réuni un groupe de travail à plusieurs
reprises qui a permis d'éviter un
certain nombre d'écueils à mon sens dans
ce texte qui était à un moment
visiblement dans dans les volontés du
gouvernement au sens large à savoir la
coupure des réseaux sociaux des
messageries en cas par exemple de
révoltes comme celle à laquelle on a pu
assister il y a quelques mois suite à la
mort du jeune Belge je vous conjure
monsieur le ministre de faire la même
chose avec ce débat qui s'ouvre
finalement sur la fin de l'anonymat sur
Internet les amendements sur les VPN ont
déjà été retirés par la majorité puisque
tout le monde s'est rendu compte que
finalement cette idée allait faire
beaucoup plus de mal que de bien je
pense qu'il faut avoir la même approche
sur le pseudo d'image j'aimerais vous
entendre là-dessus j'aimerais aussi vous
entendre sur le fait que finalement il y
a encore dans le texte l'obligation pour
les navigateurs de bloquer l'accès aux
certains sites notamment dans le cadre
du filtre anti arnaque je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
dangereux donc il y a des choses
intéressantes dans votre texte on a
envie de vous encourager pour pour
lutter évidemment contre la pédo
pornographie pour finalement lutter
contre le cyber-harcèlement mais il y a
aussi des manques sur d'autres sujets la
question de l'empreinte carbone du
numérique la question aussi de la
limitation des jeux d'argent et surtout
il y a un équilibre fondamental à
préserver entre respect des libertés et
finalement volonté de réguler l'espace
numérique et c'est là-dessus que
j'aimerais vous entendre merci merci
monsieur le député monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Député merci de me donner l'occasion
d'évoquer les travaux réalisés par ce
groupe de travail qui s'est réuni au
moment où le Sénat examinait le texte
c'est-à-dire dans les jours qu'on suivit
le début des violences
urbaines et qui s'est réuni trois fois
pour analyser à froid la place qui a pu
occuper ou copier occuper les réseaux
sociaux dans cet épisode et les leçons à
en tirer
sans entrer trop dans le détail ce que
je voudrais partager avec vous
aujourd'hui avant que le détail ne soit
donné à la première ministre qui doit
dans les jours qui viennent réunir
les membres du gouvernement qui ont
travaillé sur les suites à donner aux
émeutes et que lors de la séance
publique si les rapporteurs ils
constantes nous puissions donner des
suites je voudrais simplement en dire
que des les premiers éléments premiers
éléments d'analyse dont nous disposons
sur
sur la place des réseaux sociaux dans
les émeutes ou plutôt la place des
violences urbaines sur les réseaux
sociaux pendant cette semaine là c'est
qu'elle représente 15% de l'activité
de sur les réseaux sociaux ou sur les
principaux réseaux sociaux pendant la
semaine concernée 15% des de l'activité
à très haut violence urbaines ce qui est
considérable mais ce qui n'est pas 100%
bien évidemment et l'autre élément qui
est qui est ressorti de l'analyse un peu
quantitative qui a pu être faite de
cette épisode c'est que les appels au
calme ont été beaucoup plus nombreux que
les appels à la violence pendant la
période ce qui n'était pas forcément
attendu
ce que le ce que j'ai proposé aux
membres du groupe de travail en
particulier puisque le groupe de travail
était ouvert à tous les groupes
politiques avec un représentant par
groupe politique du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée ainsi que les présidents et
rapporteurs des deux commissions
spéciales Sena et assemblée c'est que si
les rapporteurs et consentrent qu'ils
puissent porter trois amendements et les
ouvriers s'il le souhaitent à la
co-cignature de l'ensemble des groupes
le premier dans le cas de la peine de
bannissement qui vient sanctionner
l'auteur qui contournerait le
bannissement pour se réinscrire sur la
plateforme
ce qui n'était pas prévu dans le texte
initial de prévoir que la peine de
bannissement puisse être prononcé
lorsque le Délice sous-jacent c'est
celui de provocation manifeste à la
violence qui n'est pas forcément suivi
d'un passage à l'acte et troisièmement
la création par la loi d'une réserve
citoyenne du numérique qui permettrait
de valoriser de conforter les
associations qui aujourd'hui contribuent
à l'apaisement dans l'espace numérique
sur le sujet du filtre
anti-arnac c'est c'est un dispositif qui
associe effectivement les navigateurs
les résolveurs de
DNS et les fournisseurs d'accès Internet
un certain nombre de d'inquiétudes ont
été soulevés dans le courant de l'été
sur le traitement réservé dans le
dispositif par pardon au navigateurs qui
de manière
quotidienne on l'habitude de filtrer
certains contenus mais non pas de les
bloquer
mais me semble-t-il il y a un certain
nombre d'amendements qui ont été déposés
pour affiner les choses et sur le et
voilà le gouvernement est les regards
évidemment toutes les propositions avec
beaucoup d'intérêt mais là aussi avec un
objectif qui est l'efficacité du
dispositif c'est-à-dire véritablement
protéger nos concitoyens contre
l'explosion de ces campagnes de de SMS
frauduleux et puis sur le sujet du du
pseudonymat et de l'anonymat je pense
que
on aura le débat
en commission ce que je puis dire c'est
de revenir sur la question de l'identité
numérique qui me semble être un sujet
important en lui-même et sur lequel une
une je dirais une une invitation voir
même un peu plus que cela venant du
Parlement ne sera pas inutile pour nous
permettre d'accélérer je le disais
l'identité numérique c'est aussi un
moyen de faciliter l'accès aux droits et
je pense que c'est évidemment très
souhaitable ensuite sur la question du
pseudonymat sur internet je peux
commencer si vous voulez à développer ce
qu'est
la position du gouvernement c'est que
il faudra à l'avenir qu'effectivement
comme le rapporteur général le propose
les plateformes puissent
proposer alors utilisateurs de
s'identifier s'il le souhaite pourquoi
parce que ce sera une manière pour les
utilisateurs s'il le souhaite non pas de
c'est hors de question de transférer
leurs données personnelles à
quelques plateformes que ce soit mais de
verser auprès d'un tiers de confiance
une preuve de leur identité
sans y être obligé de manière à ce
qu'ensuite lorsqu'ils évolution sur les
réseaux sociaux ils puissent aussi
choisir d'être entouré de personnes qui
comme eux ont choisi à l'entrée de ce
certifier je pense que c'est un beau
sujet que la France peut défendre
au niveau européen dans les mois qui
dans les mois qui viennent et des
échanges préliminaires que nous avons pu
avoir avec la présidence la future
présidence baisse de l'Union européenne
nous permettent de penser que des
progrès pourraient être réalisés
néanmoins je suis bien obligé d'admettre
qu'à ce stade le gouvernement ne peut
pas donner d'avis favorable sur de
telles dispositions en droit français
pour les raisons d'inconventionnalité
européenne que j'évoquais
dans mon introduction ce qui n'enlève
pas à mon avis l'intérêt de faire
cheminer l'Europe vers cet objectif là
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc
maintenant je laisse la parole à Émeline
kerbidi du groupe ZDR nups
nous examinons en effet ce jour le
projet de loi qui vise à réguler il y a
sécurisé l'espace numérique de notre
point de vue c'est un texte qui était
attendu et qui était nécessaire
puisque Internet est devenu le théâtre
quotidien des arnaques des escroquerie
du cyber-harcèlement et de tous les
autres délits en ligne on peut regretter
en effet un texte qui est très
hétéroclite pour ne pas dire un peu
fourre-tout et qui est très technique ce
qu'il rend peu intelligible
le Conseil d'État lui-même a d'ailleurs
émis certaines réserves sur la sécurité
juridique donc nous les reprenons à
notre compte
en dépit de ces observations le texte
dans l'ensemble je vous le disais nous
pas aller dans le bon sens alors bien
évidemment nous avons des interrogations
et des inquiétudes sur la protection des
données personnelles sur la protection
des libertés individuelles
et nous avons donc déposé un certain
nombre d'amendements pour améliorer et
pour sécuriser le texte nous enfonçons
peut-être des portes ouvertes sur le
rôle de la CNIL ou sur le rappel de la
protection de certaines données mais ça
nous paraissait essentiel tant le texte
est difficile et technique nous avons
également déposé un amendement sur la
sensibilisation à l'école face aux
cyber-harcèlement et je pense que tout
le monde conviendra que c'est un sujet
particulièrement brûlant avec notre
assemblée ne peut pas attendre davantage
avant de se saisir de cette
problématique
il y a certains sujets quand même qui me
semblent manquer à l'appel je n'ai pas
vu grand chose dans le texte sur la
protection du consommateur
face
au manque de sécurité
numérique de certains grosses
entreprises ou de certains grands
groupes et là-dessus il y a encore un
vide juridique et le consommateur n'est
pas suffisamment protégé vu que le texte
justement est très varié ou très
diversifié on aurait pu imaginer
rajouter là-dedans des mécanismes de
protection du consommateur je n'ai pas
vu grand chose non plus sur la fracture
numérique et j'entends par là non
seulement ceux qui n'ont pas accès à
Internet mais également ceux qui ont une
mauvaise compréhension une mauvaise
gestion de l'outil Internet cela font
des proies particulièrement facile pour
les délinquants et les criminels sur le
net et là dessus on n'a pas mis grand
chose on a des chiffres pourtant de
l'Insee qui nous indique notamment qu'en
2021 15% de la population française
connaît des difficultés dans
l'utilisation des outils numériques sur
les différents
bancs de l'Assemblée représentés dans
cette commission beaucoup ont parlé du
rôle finalement de l'éducation de la
prévention mais je tenais quand même à
préciser que si les enfants doivent être
effectivement une une cible privilégiée
pour
l'éducation à Internet et à la bonne
utilisation de l'Internet ils doivent
pas être la seule cible de nos démarches
puisque si 15% c'est la moyenne
nationale dans cette moyenne on a 36% de
retraités qui sont donc éloignés de la
gestion de l'outil Internet et 20% des
ultramarins ce qu'il a est au-dessus de
la moyenne nationale donc on ne doit pas
mettre tous nos efforts sur les enfants
il faut je pense avoir une politique à
l'adresse de l'ensemble des publics qui
sont aujourd'hui en difficulté face à
l'outil numérique et qui représente
encore une fois la cible privilégiée de
ceux qui
œuvrent sur sur le net dans toute sorte
de domaine délictuels et criminels donc
voilà un petit peu pour ce qui était de
nos remarques dans l'ensemble un projet
de loi attendu et pas si mal mais des
lacunes des inquiétudes de notre part
donc je tenais à voir un petit mot pour
ces milliers de Français d'outre-mer et
d'hexagones qui eux ne connaissent ni
les dérives
ni les bienfaits du numérique merci
merci Madame la député monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Députée vous êtes un petit peu
dur sur la protection des consommateurs
c'est vrai qu'il y a rien expressément
rien de nouveau dans le texte mais le
DMA pardon le DSA c'est les réseaux
sociaux mais c'est aussi les places de
marché et donc il n'y a pas que Facebook
et Tik Tok qui sont régulés par ce
règlement européen il y a aussi Amazon
et ainsi de suite enfin en tout cas les
places de marché notamment avec
l'interdiction d'avoir des interfaces
trompeuses avec l'obligation de vérifier
l'identité des vendeurs et puis avec des
mesures qui touchent à la pub
l’interaction de la publicité ciblée sur
les mineurs par exemple et tout ça c'est
quand même des avancées qui ne sont pas
reprises dans le texte puisque le texte
ne fait que de d'attribuer à la DGCCRF
le soin de veiller à ce que ces
obligations soient bien remplies dans
notre pays mais quand même ça ça va
faire un peu de différence
et ensuite alors sur la fracture
numérique c'est vrai qu'il y a rien dans
ce texte là mais c'est un sujet
fondamental
vous dites 15% en citant les chiffres de
l'INSEE je vous invite à consulter
l'étude que le credoch a réalisé en
début d'année et qui démontre que 30 %
des Français sont éloignés du numérique
soit parce qu'ils ne sont pas
internautes soit parce qu'ils ne sont
pas compétents alors on peut même quand
on a l'habitude de travailler avec des
tablettes etc être étonné de cet état de
fait mais en réalité quand on y pense je
pense que si on faisait un sondage tout
au fond des cœurs de chacun des présents
dans cette salle il y a bien un moment
on s'est retrouvé un petit peu perdu
face à un écran ou un ordinateur ou une
démarche en ligne et donc finalement ce
chiffre finit par prendre une certaine
réalité mais là vous avez raison en
revanche même si c'est pas 15 mais 30%,
c'est que ça n'est pas qu'un phénomène
générationnel c'est en réalité un fait
social parce que les éloignés du
numérique contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser ça ne sont pas que les
personnes âgées ce sont des personnes
qui bien souvent sont moins diplômées
qui sont plus modestes qui sont plus
souvent des ouvriers des employés que
des cadres ou des professions
intermédiaires ce sont aussi des
personnes c'est ce que disent un peu les
études qui ont pu un sentiment de
relégation et qui ont tendance à ne pas
participer aux élections et à s'abstenir
aux élections tant elles ont peut-être
le sentiment que dans cette société
numérique qui progresse elles sont
laissées sur le bord du chemin alors il
y a eu une étape de franchi en 2021
quand très généreusement Bercy avait
ouvert ses crédits et sur le plan de
relance 4000 conseillers numériques ont
été envoyés un peu partout en France je
vais pas les chiffres pour l'autre mère
mais je voulais apporterai si si vous le
souhaitez qui ont été financés par
l'État chez poste qui ont été accueillis
pour les conseillers numériques par les
collectivités les associations les
Chambres d'agriculture etc et qui font
un travail remarquable depuis deux ans
et dernière on a sanctuarisé le budget
même si la prise en charge va à l'avenir
baisser de 100% à un niveau un tout
petit peu inférieur et ce que nous avons
travaillé sous l'égide du Conseil
national la Fondation avec l'ensemble
des acteurs de la médiation numérique et
des élus locaux c'est une structuration
territoriale de cette politique
d'inclusion ça s'appelle France
Numérique ensemble c'est en train de se
déployer les préfets ont la charge de
d'identifier les collectivités qui
veulent porteurs de cette politique dans
leur territoire cette politique
d'inclusion numérique qui vont avoir la
charge de coordonner l'action à la fois
des conseils numériques mais de toutes
celles et ceux de la secrétaire de
mairie aux responsables de médiathèques
qui de près ou de loin participent à
l'accompagnement des personnes éloignées
du numérique
merci monsieur le ministre et comme un
orateur pour le groupe liote nous aurons
Christophe negelaine merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre madame
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues très rapidement ça la
régulation du numérique doit pas
forcément rimer avec restrictions de
liberté
entre un espace libertaire et la mise en
péril de la liberté d'expression doit
être en capacité de trouver une voie et
c'est ce chemin là que nous devons nous
devons emprunter
l'Union européenne à travers l'adoption
de 4 règlements posent les premiers
jalons d'un Internet plus mesuré où les
grandes plateformes et les principaux
moteurs de recherche ne décident plus
des règles du jeu
nous devons nous montrer ambitieux dans
des mesures visant à rééquilibrer le
marché européen de l'informatique en
nuage ce secteur est aujourd'hui
fortement concentré autour de trois
acteurs américains au risque de mettre
en péril de notre souveraineté numérique
nous devons être fiers de nous
entreprises du numérique nous devons les
écouter nous devons les soutenir et nous
devons aussi les protéger c'est pour ça
que monsieur le ministre nous serons
bien entendu favorables au maintien de
l'article 10 bis qui a été ajouté par le
qui a été ajouté par le Sénat de plus
nous considérons que la lutte contre la
haine sur Internet ou la protection de
l'enfance justifie d'imposer de
nouvelles règles au site internet et aux
internautes notamment la lutte contre
l'exposition des mineurs au site aux
images pornographiques mais tous ces
sujets doivent avoir un équilibre entre
d'un côté la sécurisation la protection
et de l'autre le droit à l'anonymat et
cet équilibre tout comme dans la
première partie de mon propos qui sera
la boussole de notre de notre vote et
des différents amendements que nous
déposons dans ce texte vous avez parlé
de l'hypertrucage en disant ce ministre
que cela sera sanctionné sous certaines
conditions la question qui se pose c'est
pourquoi sous certaines conditions et
certains types d'hypertrucage dès lors
que il porte atteinte dès lors qu'ils
sont malveillants ils se doivent d'être
puni et c'est vrai que le fait de faire
en fin de compte deux catégories
d'hypertrucage on peut trouver cela
dommageable on peut regretter aussi que
dans ce texte concernant les genume on
s'arrête justement entre guillemets à
ses genoux mais qu'on ne n'ouvre pas
plus loin je pense notamment à au casino
en ligne et au jeu à certains jeux en
ligne vous mettez l'occasion de
légiférer sur le sujet sur lequel en fin
de compte il y a énormément de victimes
aussi et des sites internet et certains
opérateurs qui utilisent la non
réglementation autour des jeux en ligne
pour se faire énormément d'argent au
détriment de nos concitoyens voilà très
rapidement ce que je pouvais vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre sur ce texte merci
monsieur le député monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
le Président je pense qu'on a une
boussole de la même marque puisque on
essaye également de veiller au bon
équilibre entre l'efficacité des mesures
et la préservation des libertés
fondamentales que sont la liberté
d'expression la liberté la liberté de
communication et aussi une liberté dont
on parle peut-être un peu moins souvent
ou peut-être de manière un peu moins
bruyante qui est la liberté
d'information parce qu'on va aussi sur
un certain un certain nombre
d'interfaces pour s'informer avant même
de commencer à communiquer
sur les deep fake alors les
hypertruquage oui il y a deux articles
il y a deux articles qui ont été créés
le premier pour faire rentrer dans le
code pénal
la pénalisation des hyper trucages
lorsqu'ils sont fait sans le
consentement la personne ou sans qu'ils
ne soient évident que c'est un que c'est
un trucage et
que c'est fait à des fins de nuire à la
personne mais on va pas interdire les
bébêtes chauds de
l'air de l'intelligence artificielle si
on peut dire rouler Guignols de l'Info
de l'air de l'intelligence artificielle
de betho
oui
attention ne pas oui attention
concentration et le deuxième c'est les
deep fake les hyper trucages porno ou là
il est considéré c'est pour ça qu'il on
souhaite rester sur deux dispositifs il
est souhaité que c'est nécessairement
malveillant et là il y a des conditions
qui sautent parce que là la question ne
se pose pas et sur les jaunes nuls voilà
c'est un gros travail
je à nouveau je veux je veux rendre
hommage à tout le travail qui a été
réalisé à la fois par les services de
Bercy dans leur multitude mais aussi par
les rapporteurs parce que si nous avons
souhaité avec les rapporteurs essayer
d'avancer sur cette question c'est
encouragé par le succès que nous avons
rencontré il y a quelques années lorsque
Bruno Le Maire a voulu que nous
puissions port un cadre qui est celui
des prestataires de services sur actifs
numériques qui sous pression des
parlementaires à l'époque c'était au
moment de l'examen de la loi pacte a
réussi à trouver le bon équilibre entre
la protection des
épargnants des investisseurs d'un côté
et la flexibilité nécessaire pour
l'innovation à l'époque franchement et
je reconnais quelques visages qui
étaient présents dans l'hémicycle tout
le monde n'était pas totalement
convaincu mais avec 5 ans de recul on
s'aperçoit qu'on a eu raison parce que
non seulement on a eu plutôt de bonnes
surprises des implantations en France
d'entreprises qui sont venus s'installer
pour développer y compris de l'emploi et
de l'activité mais aussi que l'Europe
s'est inspirée du cadre français pour
réguler ses activités nouvelles si bien
que la France est désormais considérée
dans comme étant la voix de passage pour
ceux qui veulent développer de
l'activité en Europe l'Europe l'Europe
étant considérée comme étant évidemment
mieux régulé que les États-Unis ou ces
activités là ne sont toujours pas
régulées du tout et bien c'est un peu ce
même équilibre qu'on espère réussir à
trouver pour ces activités nouvelles que
sont les jeux objets numériques
monétisable merci monsieur le ministre
nous avons fini donc avec les orateurs
de groupe on va passer aux orateurs
individuels je rappelle que
puisque on avait laissé les le ministre
répondent à chacune des orateurs de
groupe les orateurs de groupe neuront
pas la possibilité de poser des
questions donc on commence par donc
c'est une minute et une minute et une
réponse se collective
Carole Parmentier Caroline pardon
Parmentier pour le groupe rassemblement
national
excusez-moi merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il n'a jamais été
aussi facile aujourd'hui pour des
enfants d'accéder à des contenus
pornographiques à des contenus de plus
en plus violents et toxiques pour eux ce
projet de loi apporte par la création
des référentiels un outil qui sera
assurément efficace pour mieux protéger
notre jeunesse en luttant contre sa
facilité d'accès aux visionnage des
contenus pornographiques mais de
nombreux jeunes ayant déjà visionné ces
contenus souffrent d'addiction la
réponse par est tardif pour eux on sait
que les images véhiculées par la
pornographie traumatise et affecte
durablement et profondément de nombreux
jeunes dans la construction de leur
personnalité il faut les aider
pouvez-vous m'indiquer quelles sont
selon vous les outils susceptibles
d'être développés pour lutter contre
l'addiction à la pornographie des jeunes
que pensez-vous de la remise d'un
rapport au Parlement consacré à lutter
contre cette addiction à la pornographie
j'attire enfin votre attention sur le
Conseil français des associations pour
les droits de l'enfant qui a estimé dans
une lettre au président de la République
et à la première ministre que les
dispositions actuelles du texte du texte
risquaient de produire les effets
inverse de ce escompté pouvez-vous nous
éclairer également sur cette mise en
garde des associations de protection de
l'enfance je vous remercie maintenant
Philippe Balard pour le groupe
rassemblement national
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
monsieur le ministre ma question portera
plus précisément sur l'article 6 du
projet de loi alors je vais me réjouis
dans un premier temps que vous ayez
proposé avec ce toit de mettre en place
un réel moyen d'action afin de protéger
les consommateurs français face à la
recrudescence des arnaques en tout genre
je me pose néanmoins la question de
savoir si vous n'aurez pas la main qui
tremble le moment venu notamment du fait
que le blocage soit vraisemblablement
stoppé en cas de recours il me semble
important de protéger les utilisateurs
durant la durée du recours administratif
exercée par la personne dont l'activité
est d'éditer le service de communication
au public en ligne le blocage étant
suspendu le temps du recours il me
paraît important que l'utilisateur soit
informé par un message d'avertissement
comme prévu lors de la première phase
pré blocage du risque de préjudice
encourus en cas d'accès à l'adresse
électronique de ce service pourquoi
avoir retiré ce dispositif durant la
phase de recours administratif je
remercie merci la parole est à
Jean-François Coulomb de LFI
hop merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement est Bruno Le Maire l'ont
répété la protection de nos données
relève de notre sécurité de notre
souveraineté numérique pourtant la
migration de nos données de santé hors
du cloud de Microsoft azur qui devait
avoir lieu en 2022 a été retardé par le
gouvernement à l'horizon 2025 malgré la
vie de la CNIL dans cette lignée au lieu
de lutter pour une souveraineté
française du stockage de nos données ce
texte présente de nombreuses mesures
d'adaptation du digital services actes
qui prévoit qu'un plus grand nombre de
données détenues par le secteur public
soit éligible au droit de réutilisation
dès le 24 septembre 2023
vous déplorez la main mise des gafams
sur l'économie du cloud ou Amazon Google
et Apple écrase la concurrence avec plus
de 70% des parts de Cloud en France en
parallèle la Commission européenne a
adopté le 10 juillet 2023 une nouvelle
décision d'adéquation avec les
États-Unis permettant ainsi le transfert
de données personnelles depuis l'UE vers
les organismes états-iens librement sans
encadrement spécifique quand la sécurité
de ces données le texte que vous
proposez n'offre que des mesures
déclaratives du prestataire de Cloud
pour l'essentiel monsieur le ministre
nous vous demandons pourquoi les notions
d'espace français souvent de stockage et
de transparence sur la territorialité de
traitement des données sont absentes
je laisse la parole à Andy kerbra du
groupe LFI merci monsieur le président
cette loi c'est l'art de passer à côté
du vrai problème
vous nous avez expliqué monsieur le
ministre en préambule
la réalité selon vous de ce qu'on fait
nos partenaires australiens anglais et
même indien avec une vision un peu
faussée il faut le dire vous êtes parti
de l'exemple d'abord australien en vous
cachant derrière le référentiel pour
techniciser le débat mais la réalité
c'est lisse et petit comme une chaîne
heure qui avait recommandé en mars 2023
un système de vérification d'âge n'a pas
pris le risque de proposer une technique
on le sait tous et ça a été abordé et
retiré par nos collègues de la majorité
que l'usage du VPN tel qu'il est fera
que une vérification d'âge ne marchera
pas donc j'ai qu'une seule question
monsieur le ministre
pourquoi préférez-vous encourager à la
censure et donc prendre le risque de
censurer des dispositifs qui
permettraient d'aider à la sexualité
d'aider à lutter contre les VIH ou les
IST plutôt que faire de l'éducation
c'est ce que nous demande merci monsieur
le député je laisse la parole à y dire
boomertit
merci Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues à une heure où l'on constate
la prépondérance du tout numérique un
projet de loi visant à la sécuriser et
le réguler le bienvenu toutefois les
annonces faites à la suite des révoltes
urbaines cet été relatives à la
possibilité de réguler ou couper les
réseaux sociaux nous alertes le
caractère autoritaire de ce type de
censure n'est observable que dans des
régimes autoritaires suite à ces
annonces des représentants de
plateformes de réseaux sociaux comme Tik
Tok ou snapchat ont affirmé avoir
supprimé de nombreux contenus ce texte
de loi permet au navigateur Internet de
bloquer l'accès à des sites catégorisés
de malveillants par une autorité
administrative or aucun pays
démocratique n'a encore osé porter une
telle atteinte à la liberté sur Internet
d'abord pour les députés insoumis seul
le juge judiciaire devrait avoir la
possibilité d'exercer un pouvoir de
censure ensuite les navigateurs ne
peuvent devenir les outils d'une censure
au gouvernementale ainsi au vu du risque
de censure qui pourrait être appliquée
par des gouvernements qui répriment la
liberté d'expression alors que de
nombreuses associations dénoncent cette
mesure
monsieur le ministre quel réel garantit
pouvez-vous apporter dans ce texte merci
monsieur le député la parole est
désormais à Estelle folesté
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je suis pour ma part
particulièrement attentive à la
protection des mineurs en ligne à cet
égard je me réjouis vraiment très
vivement de toutes les mesures adoptées
par le DSA en particulier celle relative
à l'évaluation et la correction des
risques systémiques auxquels les
plateformes est très grande plateformes
notamment sont soumises encore
faudra-t-il bien entendu veiller à leur
mise en œuvre mais je dois dire en effet
que c'est vraiment une très grande
avancée de même que le projet de loi que
nous examinons déjà et qui apportera une
nouvelle pierre à l'édifice alors vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de d'un
dispositif et c'est vrai qui qui
comprend plusieurs pierres
il y en a un sur lequel j'aimerais
insister c'est la responsabilisation et
l'accompagnement des parents les deux à
la fois sur lequel malheureusement et je
le déplore on ne peut pas faire grand
chose dans ce projet de loi
j'aimerais savoir ce que le gouvernement
entend faire à cet égard parce que dans
la société dans la vie réelle c'est ce
que les parents nous demandent
essentiellement les aider et les
accompagner pour régler les différents
qui les opposent de plus en plus à leurs
enfants quant aux écrans je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est désormais à Laurent est-ce
que Netbox
c'est bien dit merci Monsieur président
monsieur le ministre depuis 2017 depuis
2007 les sites pornographiques sont
obligés d'empêcher l'accès aux mineurs
les plateformes ne font que dans très
peu de cas font très peu de cas de cette
loi se contentent d'une déclaration de
majorité où on appuie sur un bouton
puisque 30% de leur public à moins de 18
ans gageons que celle-ci n'a dû stopper
que très peu de nos jeunes malgré les
procédures engagées depuis 2018 l'accès
au site pornographique reste aussi
simple que celui vers La Redoute
Carrefour ou la Fnac.com sur le site que
même mais désormais tout va aller plus
vite l'instauration d'un référentiel ne
versera plus au plateforme de prétexter
l'impossibilité technique le blocage
direct par l'arcom accélèrera
l'effectivité des sanctions toutefois
alors que l'article 227-24 du code pénal
impose déjà une obligation de résultat
le craignez-vous pas que la rédaction
actuelle du texte n'entraîne les
plateformes pornographiques vers une
simple obligation de moyens à savoir
respecter le référentiel de la com dans
l'obstant l'efficacité de leur filtrage
comment concilier les objectifs du code
pénal avec ceux de ces nouvelles
dispositions je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est
désormais un Soumia
le micro s'il vous plaît monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre moi
j'aimerais ça me fait m'en revenir
j'aimerais avoir des explications sur
l'article 4B que mon groupe le groupe
GDR a déposé qu'on avait inséré qui a
été déclaré et recevable car cavalier
donc demandons simplement au
gouvernement de remettre au Parlement
dans un délai de dooms mois après la
promenergation de la loi un rapport qui
contient les propositions concrètes qui
permettent d'avoir des statistiques et
peut-être des analyses fines sur les
plaintes des victimes des violences
commises dans un contexte de
pornographie de pornographie et ainsi
d'améliorer les conditions d'accueil des
victimes de viol d'agression sexuelle ça
permettrait également peut-être une
formation qui soit beaucoup plus adaptée
des forces de l'ordre qui recueillent
les plaintes des victimes et à meilleur
suivi des dossiers voilà donc j'aimerais
avoir des précisions sur sur cet
amendement qui ne paraissait très
intéressant et très important pour pour
la défense des droits des femmes et qui
vous semble qui a été cavalier merci
merci je laisse la parole à Clara
chassagnol
je le souhaite grâce à ce texte apporter
des garanties importantes contre
l'impunité sur Internet et pour protéger
nos concitoyens or nous savons pour
apporter des réponses en matière de
gestion des contenus ici les réponses
pénales ou administratives nécessitent
des moyens humains et financiers pour
traiter les différentes demandes pour
cela l'année dernière nous avons adopté
deux lois d'orientation et de
programmation majeures pour renforcer
les moyens du ministère de l'intérieur
avec 1500 cyber patrouilleurs et pour la
justice en consacrant une hausse
budgétaire inédite aussi à quelques
jours de la présentation de la loi de
finances je souhaitais vous interroger
sur l'assurance que nous pouvons avoir
concernant les moyens dont l'état
disposera au sein de Pharos de l'arcome
et de la CNIL si cette loi est adoptée
pour qu'elle soit réellement appliquée
afin d'éviter une nouvelle forme
d'impuissance de l'État que nous
souhaitons résoudre dans le traitement
des activités illicites sur internet je
vous remercie
merci la parole est désormais à Céline
Calvez
le président monsieur le ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs je
souhaitais particulièrement attirer
votre attention sur le sujet de la
transparence algorithmique les
algorithmes déterminent désormais ce que
nous voyons sur les réseaux sociaux les
résultats de nos recherches sur Internet
les recommandations des produits des
articles médiatiques en ligne soumis aux
utilisateurs et bien d'autres ces
algorithmes jouent donc un rôle de plus
en plus près pondérant dans notre vie
quotidienne la nôtre et celle de nous
citoyens par conséquent la manière dont
ces algorithmes sont conçus utilisés à
un impact considérable sur notre société
il apparaît essentiel de peaufiner les
mécanismes de régulation dont nous
disposons afin de garantir la
transparence de ces systèmes à cette fin
le règlement européen DSA a permis un
renforcement des pouvoirs de contrôle
des autorités en leur confiant la
possibilité d'obtenir davantage
d'informations de la part des
plateformes sur la conception
l'utilisation de leur formule
algorithmique aussi pourriez-vous nous
faire part de vos réflexions quant aux
évolutions à apporter à notre système
législatif afin de garantir un respect
de ces applications et une réelle
transparence des algorithmes je vous
remercie
merci la parole est désormais à Philippe
Gosselin merci monsieur le Président
quelques mots simplement pour rappeler
que aujourd'hui nous avons un texte
important mais qu'il en existe d'autres
avant voilà on n'est pas au premier jour
d'une découverte en 78 la CNIL avait été
créée après tout un débat d'ailleurs un
peu compliqué sur des fichiers en 2004
il y a eu des modifications rgpd 2018
voilà donc on ne patient pas sur le sur
le vide et du sable maintenant ne pas
laisser penser même si ce texte va
vraiment dans le bon sens et nous le
soutenons ne pas laisser penser qu'il
permettra de résoudre toutes les
questions liées à la pornographie toutes
les questions qui sont liées aux
arnaques toutes les questions qui sont
liées au jeu j'en passe et des meilleurs
pas plus sur les diphake et autres donc
il serait illusoire de penser que c'est
une une arme absolue et je crois qu'il
faut aussi par ailleurs et justement en
complémentairement avoir un contrôle
parental poussé une éducation au
numérique qui soit importante et avoir
des moyens je plaide évidemment pour la
comme la CNIL l'ARCEP parce que sans
moyens tout cela sera fin
merci monsieur le député je laisse la
parole désormais à Stéphane vogeta
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en 1998 NTM disait laisse pas
traîner ton fils désormais les pièges
qui guettent notre jeunesse ne
l'attendent plus seulement dans les
caves obscures des HLM ces pièges sont
souvent dans l'espace numérique et il
est de notre devoir d'aider les parents
à en protéger les enfants je salue ce
projet de loi et la volonté qu'il
manifeste de restreindre l'accès des
mineurs au porno mais sa version
actuelle
ignore malheureusement un angle mort
tout aussi indésirable les plateformes
de pornographie sur demande je parle de
ces jeunes filles qui ouvrent un compte
sur onlyfans ou surim et il poste des
vidéos pornographiques contre
rémunération rien ne peut être pris en
cible en soi bien sûr si ce n'est que
des mineurs peuvent être exposés à la
promotion de ses comptes sur Twitter ou
sur Instagram pire encore le business
d'agent only fans ça existe et c'est un
secteur florissant qui consiste à
parcourir Instagram snapchat ou Tik Tok
en quête de jeune fille que l'on
convaincra d'ouvrir un contenu fans pour
en tirer un revenu dans l'argent
profitera bien sûr à la jambe bref un
business de rabatteur pour ne pas dire
de soutenir donc 25 ans après Kool Shen
et Joey Starr on est donc désormais
tenté de dire laisse pas traîner ta
fille sur Instagram et même si les
amendements que le groupe de travail
transpartisans sur les influenceurs ont
été déclarés irrecevables j'espère que
le gouvernement prendra ce sujet à bras
le corps et proposera une rédaction qui
permettrait de restreindre les effets
indésirables des activités
si Monsieur le Député je laisse la
parole à Fabienne Colboc
uler l'espace numérique protéger les
enfants de la pornographie en ligne
protéger contre les arnaques le
harcèlement et la désinformation en
ligne et des mesures aussi sur les
entreprises et location touristiques les
jeux mais de nouveau et de nouveaux
pouvoirs pour les autorités chargées du
DSA et du DMA mais je souhaiterais ici
aborder celui de l'encadrement de
l'intelligence artificielle notamment ce
qui concerne les droits d'auteurs des
solutions novatrices émergent pour la
protection et la gestion des droits liés
aux photos notamment en parallèle
l'Europe prend des mesures avec
l'artificiel intelligence acte néanmoins
les inquiétudes existent parmi les
auteurs dont leur œuvre ne bénéficie pas
de protection sur leurs droits d'auteur
lorsque celle-ci sont utilisées par des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
monsieur le ministre quelle mesure
peuvent être envisagées pour encadrer
ces pratiques et répondre à ces
inquiétudes je vous remercie merci le
député je laisse la parole à Violette
subilgo
qui est plus là donc à Philippe la tombe
merci monsieur le Président quand on dit
que ce qui est interdit dans le monde
physique doit l'être dans le monde
numérique c'est trop simple trop
lapidaire et pas nuancé c'est tellement
faux technologiquement faux
juridiquement inexact et
philosophiquement discutable pour autant
ça veut pas dire qu'il ne faut rien
faire et vous ne trouvez toujours sur ce
chemin nous avons néanmoins vu fleurir
depuis quelques jours des Marronniers en
automne des amendements anti VPN ou
l'amendement du rapporteur général
contre l'anonymat un amendement plaque
d'immatriculation monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous rappeler ce que la
Commission vous a indiqué comme ce qui
ressort de la libre possibilité de
législation nationale et enfin je
rejoins interrogation soulevée par notre
collègue prud'hommes sur le Cloud et la
souveraineté des données sensibles
notamment celle de des données de santé
de nos concitoyens je remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole était
désormais à Jean-Jacques gold TI
merci président la définition des jeunes
repose toujours sur les quatre
conditions qui qualifient l'activité de
jeux d'argent n'y a-t-il pas alors un
risque que les opérateurs illégaux de
casino en ligne puisse intégrer cette
catégorie alors même que l'offre
illégale de casino en ligne a vraiment
proliféré en France et ces dernières
années l'autorité nationale des jeux
estime entre 1 et 2 millions de joueurs
sur ces sites y a-t-il pas aussi
distorsion de concurrence avec les
casinos terrestres dont l'activité en
ligne est interdite et pourquoi ne pas
expérimenter aussi l'autorisation des
casino terrestres à exploiter à distance
une offre digitale afin de permettre de
canaliser ces joueurs français qui
fréquentent une offre illégale vers une
offre sécurisée contrôlée fiscalisé en
préservant les emplois et aussi un
retour vers les territoires et notamment
beaucoup de territoires ruraux
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Caroline yadan
merci Monsieur le Ministre l'article 4B
du projet de loi introduit par nos
collègues c'est la terre vise à
permettre aux personnes qui ont tourné
un film pornographique d'obtenir son
délai et gratuitement le retrait de ce
Contenu dès lors qu'il continue d'être
diffusé sur Internet au-delà de la
période contractuelle ou lorsque la
diffusion ne respecte pas les modalités
prévues si cette initiative va dans le
bon sens et emporte évidemment mon total
soutien je souhaite savoir si le
dispositif de cet article pourrait être
étendu aux autres contenus à caractère
sexuel diffusé sans consentement pour
inclure toutes les potentiels victimes
de diffusion non consenties de contenu à
caractère sexuel je vous remercie
merci Madame la député la parole est
désormais à Rémi réberrotte
Président chers collègues
cette loi je dirais enfin cette nouvelle
loi pourquoi parce que j'ai entendu tout
à l'heure une référence à la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen
c'est vrai qu'elle dit dans son article
11 qu'il faut respecter la liberté de
penser d'écrire d'imprimer elle rappelle
également dans le même article sauf à
répondre de l'abus de cette liberté dans
les cas déterminés par la loi et elle
fait référence à l'article 4 la liberté
consiste à pouvoir faire tout ce qui ne
nuit pas à autrui or nous avons
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux trop
de nos concitoyens qui souffrent
d'abus qui souffrent d'usage abusif
haine raciste xénophobes sexistes
homophobe d'harcèlement
et sous diverses formes à travers le net
bien sûr il faut prendre la
sécurité que ce soit le juge qui puisse
passer du pseudo à la levée de
l'anonymat et c'est ce qui sera proposé
mais je crois que cette loi elle est
aujourd'hui indispensable parce que je
le redis trop de nos concitoyens
souffrent aujourd'hui d'un
usage abusif pas de l'usage du net ou
d'Internet d'un usage abusif des réseaux
sociaux devenus parfois à sociaux merci
monsieur le député
le dernier inscrite et Virginie dubis
Muller à moins qu'il y ait quelqu'un
d'autre qui le souhaite et à ce
moment-là fait signe s'il vous plaît aux
administrateurs
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
revenir effectivement sur ce texte qui
est ambitieux je tiens à saluer le
travail des sénateurs qui a d'ailleurs
été enrichi par les travaux de la
délégation droit des femmes et de la
commission des affaires européennes et
qui a aboutit à une version qui nous
paraît équilibrée je vais pas revenir
sur les mesures clés mais je voulais
insister sur un article sur lequel on
tient particulièrement qui est le 10 A
sur la protection des données
stratégiques et sensibles sur le marché
de l'informatique en nuage qui permet
donc de renforcer la transparence et la
protection de nos données stratégiques
et sensibles notamment celle de santé et
je partage les inquiétudes de Philippe
latonde afin de doter la France et
l'Europe bien sûr d'une plus grande
autonomie stratégique et d'accompagner
le développement de l'industrie
française et européenne et je voulais
également citer le rapport du Conseil de
l'Union européenne assez récent qui
s'inquiète de notre dépendance aux
entreprises extra-européennes justement
dans nos infrastructures et notamment de
Cloud et rappeler que seuls 14% des
services Cloud en Europe sont conçus en
Europe
et qui a donc un risque de dépendance
majeur et donc je souhaitais bien sûr
vous alerter sur ce point merci merci
madame la députée monsieur le ministre
pour une réponse collective merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président et
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés la
question de Madame Parmentier sur les
outils contre les addictions et rapports
sur les addictions ma réponse elle va
être simple il faut juste mettre un
filtre
pardon je veux pas qu'on confond les
articles une vérification d'âge à
l'entrée des sites ce que l'addiction
elle n'est de l'exposition et
l'exposition aujourd'hui elle est
endémique elle est massive je n'ai pas
le chiffre de l'exposition accidentelle
des mineurs à la pornographie en France
mais lorsque Madame la Commissaire
australienne est venue elle m'a donné un
chiffre très intéressant un tiers des
enfants australiens de 17 ans sont
exposés à la pornographie de manière
accidentelle donc je sais qu'on va avoir
des débats sur oh là là est-ce que la
vérification d'âge c'est qu'on
tournables c'est pas contournable le
simple fait de mettre une vérification
d'âge si les chiffres sont comparables
en France à ceux de l'Australie ça veut
dire qu'il y a un tiers des enfants de
10 à 13 ans auquel on va
éviter qu'on va soustraire au
déferlement des images pornographiques
en libre accès sur sur internet à la
question de Monsieur Balard sur
l'article 6
donc sur le filtre est-ce que le recours
doit être suspensif ou non il est prévu
dans le texte du Gouvernement que le
recours soit suspensif c'était une
demande de la CNIL et à vrai dire quand
on se figure le type d'acteur qui peut
faire un recours parce qu'il
estimerait avoir été surfiltré on peut
se dire que c'est a priori un acteur
bienveillant et qu'il est plutôt naturel
de suspendre le le filtrage blocage
parce que sinon s'il est un acteur
malveillant il va pas aller se signaler
aux autorités en disant
lever s'il vous plaît le blocage et le
filtrage
aux questions de Monsieur Coulomme qui
voilà qui qui sont qui sont réévoqués
par Monsieur latombe par Madame dubis
Muller sur le 10 bis high le 10 bisb
j'ai dit tout à l'heure j'y reviens pas
longuement les raisons pour lesquelles
on pense que c'est contre-productif pour
l'objectif qu'on partage très largement
de sécurisation des données sensibles
personnelles et non personnelles des
Français que d'aller trop vite dans
l'extension de l'obligation
et sur le 10 bisbé qui est une
obligation d'information je crois que
Madame la rapporteur fera des
propositions qui tiendront compte
d'ailleurs de certaines des remarques
des questions qui ont été soulevées soit
dans les auditions soit dans les
échanges que vous avez pu avoir avec
elle sur la question de Monsieur
Kerbrat oui je pense qu'il y a quand
même une question un peu de technicité
enfin c'est il faut pas verser dans le
solutionnisme il faut pas prétendre que
ce texte résout tout mais il y a quand
même des sujets
techniques qu'on va devoir aborder dans
ce texte et en particulier ce
référentiel sur la vérification d'âge
j'ai vu un certain nombre d'amendements
qui qui voudrait encadrer la conception
par l'arcom de ce référentiel en
veillant à ce qu'il puisse y avoir du
une préservation des données
personnelles de l'anonymat etc
on pourra en rediscuter
moi ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'effectivement il puisse y avoir une
palette d'outils qui soient disponible
mais que on puisse proposer
systématiquement ou en tout cas que les
sites en question soit amenés à proposer
au moins une solution qui respecte un
principe de tiers de confiance c'est à
dire que la preuve à partir d'une preuve
anonyme de majorité on puisse accéder à
ses services le service ne sait pas qui
est la personne qui accède et le
prestataire qui a fourni la preuve
anonyme de majorité ne sait pas ce à
quoi elle a servi au moins une solution
comme ça et puis ensuite d'autres
solutions à condition qu'elle soit
suffisamment fiables et suffisamment
robuste et je pense que peut-être dans
dans ce cas raté en Australie c'est que
des solutions comme celle-ci elle
n'existaient pas encore alors nous avons
veillé depuis les premiers jours à
inviter des entreprises françaises à se
lancer dans des expér imentations je
crois que vous en avez auditionné
certaines je dis pas que ça marche plein
tubes pour le moment mais nous avons une
liste d'entreprises qui expérimente avec
une liste de sites pornos et je suis
confiant que ces expérimentations vont
permettre de définir un modèle
d'affaires qui permettront à ces
solutions d'être soutenables
sur les questions de Monsieur
boumertite
les sites qui vont être filtrés par le
filtre anti arnaque
c'est autorité administrative oui mais
c'est une liste très limitative de
délits si vous regardez bien l'article
qui sont visés et par ailleurs d'autres
pays démocratiques ont d'ores et déjà
mis en oeuvre ce type de disposition je
pense à Belgique au Royaume-Uni au aux
Espagnols et donc étant donné les
protections avec lesquelles on a entouré
le dispositif je pense que le bon
équilibre est trouvé modulo les
évolutions qui peuvent intervenir
en fonction des propositions des
rapporteurs notamment pour voilà le bon
équilibre entre efficacité préservation
des libertés madame follès vous avez
raison d'insister sur la responsabilité
des parents
ça se pose dans l'espace numérique ça se
pose plus largement la question du
traitement des fléaux que sont le
harcèlement et le harcèlement je
ne comptais pas sur moi pour annoncer en
avance que seront les mesures présentées
par la première ministre et autour
d'elle le ministre d'éducation nationale
moi-même et peut-être d'autres sur le
plan de lutte contre le harcèlement et
le cyber-harcèlement je crois qu'il faut
s'appuyer sur le même esprit que celui
qui a régné sur le le en tout cas qui a
présidé à la à la loi Studer à la loi
Marc angélique et celle d'activer la
responsabilité parentale c'est-à-dire le
contrôle parental sur les appareils pour
la loi Studer le contrôle parental ou ou
le recueil du consentement parental pour
l'inscription sur les réseaux sociaux
dans le cadre de la loi Marc Angeli la
question de Monsieur esquenneth box je
mesure
le l'inquiétude qui a été qu'à soulever
la nouvelle nouvelles rédaction du
dispositif article article 2 par rapport
à celui de la loi du 30 juillet 2020 les
articles 23 et 24 ou 22 et 23
comme j'ai pu l'évoquer avec certains
d'entre vous je suis je suis preneur
d'une
d'une rédaction qui nous permet d'avoir
à la fois l'objectif l'objectif de
résultat l'objectif de moyen mais à ce
stade nous n'avons pas trouvé une
rédaction qui apparaît suffisamment
solide à au ministère de la Justice et
s'agissant d'articles qui vont être
apprenant contestée par les sites
pornographiques que nous entendons
réguler il faut qu'on soit parfaitement
vigilant et donc à ce stade on sera pas
en mesure de d'avancer sur cette
question mais je je reste je reste
ouvert si nous parvenons sans affaiblir
le dispositif à viser à la fois les
moyens et le résultat
sur la question de Madame chassagnol sur
les autres moyens je pense c'est
important de les rappeler que nous
déployons pour ou que le gouvernement
déploie pour et bien sécuriser l'espace
numérique il n'y a pas que les règles
qui sont fixées dans ce texte j'ai
évoqué un peu plus tôt les moyens
déployés parmi cercle intérieur
il sera désormais possible de porter
plainte derrière son écran par
visio-conférence grâce à la locmin la
loi d'orientation de programmation de
ministère d'intérieur que vous avez
adopté en janvier dernier qui sera
possible pour les victimes d'avoir un
avocat avec elle et ça c'est très
important pour les victimes de
harcèlement lorsqu'elles sont créatrices
en ligne par exemple lors du dépôt de
plainte l'application ma sécurité
permettra de déposer plainte en ligne et
à terme de suivre son traitement en 2023
et force de sécurité intérieure quant à
elle recevront des kits de formation
pour la prise des plaintes de cyber
violence grâce au plan pour l'égalité
entre les femmes et hommes portés par
Isabelle borne et Isabelle Rome le 8
mars dernier et puis pour la justice les
moyens vont augmenter de manière
historique dans les prochaines semaines
et notamment recrutement 10 000
personnels magistrats et greffiers
évidemment que ça va permettre sans
doute de d'instruire les
les procédures qui seront déclenchées au
titre des violences en ligne et du
harcèlement à la question de ces de
Madame Calvez sur la transparence des
algorithmes je dirais que
vous avez
avec le DSA l'obligation d'audit de ces
algorithmes le partage des données avec
les chercheurs qui vont donc pouvoir
mettre à jour un certain nombre des
défauts des défaillances de ces systèmes
il y a des éléments qui s'ajoutent à ça
et en particulier
la
les rapports annuels de transparence que
les autorités enfin que les plateformes
vont remettre la Commission européenne
et au coordinateurs des services
numériques l'interdiction des Dark
patterns mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas
au DSA dans le règlement sur
l'intelligence artificielle vous allez
avoir une transparence accrue des
algorithmes alors d'intelligence
artificielle pour les systèmes à Auris
veut dire lorsque l'intelligence
artificielle est utilisée sur des
systèmes qui peuvent
causer des des risques et notamment pour
la vie humaine mais l'histoire ne
s'arrête pas là puisque nous allons
ouvrir avec les états généraux de
l'information un débat sur ces questions
là et je pense que cette la question de
savoir si le DSA le règlement sur
intelligence artificielle sont allés
suffisamment loin aussi il faut d'ores
et déjà indiqué à la future Commission
qui sera installée dans moins d'un an
qu'il faut qu'elle aille plus loin sur
ces questions bien de de le faire à ce à
ce moment là
sur la question de
Madame Colboc j'en profite pour dire que
dans quelques minutes la première
ministre va présider le la réunion de
lancement du comité stratégique pour
l'intelligence artificielle avec
différents chantiers ouverts dont celui
de la protection des du droit d'auteur
mais bref de des ayants droits pour la
culture en général et dans un élan
conjoint avec les états généraux de
l'information nous apporter je l'espère
des pistes de régulation
à la question de Monsieur la tombe je
veux d'ores et déjà
je peux répondre très rapidement que la
Commission européenne n'attendra pas des
semaines pour nous écrire si nous
prenions des dispositions quel juge
comme étant incompatible ou en piétant
sur l'empire du DSA ou même sur l'empire
précédent qui était celui de la
directive e-commerce elle le fait
régulièrement et lorsqu'elle le fait
évidemment elle fragilise énormément la
France puisque les acteurs régulés
peuvent se prévaloir d'une opposition de
la commission au disposition y compris
votée par le Parlement français pour
aller ensuite les contester devant les
addictions européennes la question de
Madame Adam sur l'extension du 4B au
violence sexuelles je pense que c'est
quelque chose vers lequel nous peniner
j'ai pas en tête la vie du rapporteur
général mais je pense que c'est une
ouverture qui me paraît raisonnable à la
question monsieur Gosselin qui est
fondamental et qui se pose à la fois au
niveau français mais aussi au niveau
européen parce que c'est bien beau
d'avoir la Commission en charge de la
régulation de
des plateformes et des contrôleurs
d'accès mais enfin il y a quand même des
sanctions extrêmement lourdes qui sont
prévues par ces textes et donc il faut
pas croire que on peut s'improviser
régulateur alors il y avait des
inquiétudes au départ mais la Commission
européenne a recruté au moins 100
personnes pour en application du DSA et
quant à l'arcom ces effectifs ont été
relevés de 15 ETP au PLF 2023 seront
relevés de 10 EP supplémentaires au PLF
2024 avec ses 25 personnes nous avons
bon espoir qu'elles puissent accomplir
ces nouvelles missions dans les
meilleures conditions
à la question de Monsieur Gauthier alors
la question des casinos en ligne a été
jugé il recevable au Sénat elle est à
nouveau à l'Assemblée
c'est une c'est un secteur qui
dans le comment dire dans la régulation
est traditionnelle en placée entre les
mains de la direction du budget et donc
du ministre des comptes publics je n'ai
étant donné l'irrecevabilité des
amendements pas pris le temps d'en
parler avec lui mais j'entends
pour des sujets de protection des mines
d'argent je pense très honnêtement qu'il
y aura peu de frottements entre le
casino physique et les genume parce qu'à
mon avis ce sont des activités qui sont
suffisamment différentes mais c'est une
expérimentation il faudra en tirer le
bilan et s'il y a trop de frottements il
faudra évidemment que chacun puisse
vivre que chacun soit régulier en
fonction des activités qu'il mène
ensuite sur la pertinence de ce que de
la proposition que vous évoquez que
d'autres ont porté je pense qu'il ne que
c'est pas parce qu'elle a été
irrecevable pour ce texte qu'il faut
cesser complètement d'y penser ne
serait-ce que pour la protection des
mineurs la protection contre les
addictions puisqu'on sait que il y a du
jeu en ligne qui contourne les
interdictions qui sont faites au niveau
national et ça à un moment donné ça
devra nous poser question la question de
Madame Bourgoin sur l'amendement
irrecevable je veux bien le regarder et
vous dire plus précisément
éventuellement identifier un vecteur à
venir et je crois que j'ai répondu U à
l'ensemble sauf à monsieur reberotte qui
a lui aussi cité l'article 11 et
l'article 4 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme qui éclaireront nos débats un
lampadaire
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
merci pour la précision de vos réponses
surtout que je sais que vous êtes
attendus donc je vous propose de clore
cette discussion générale je vous
remercie tous les orateurs et tous les
intervenants et nous nous retrouvons à
21h30 pour le début de l'examen des
articles